we are here ladies and gentlemen in Iowa
only a few days out from the Iowa caucus
where I think it's fair to say Donald
Trump is going to win but you know I
guess people are here trying to beat him
now right now there's a blizzard they're
calling it a once in a decade blizzard I
think it's not even a big deal you know
I'm I'm I'm from Chicago walking around
there's snow everywhere and all these
stores are shut down we walk down to a
restaurant to get lunch they're closed
and I'm like okay well you know I
respect it they don't people they're
trying to be safe to be fair it's like
crazy white out conditions it's you're
driving on the highway there's drift you
can't really see but I feel like the
people of Iowa can handle this it's not
that big a deal but it is it is pretty
wild considering uh that you have
someone like Ronda santz currently here
when uh there's a state of emergency
going on in Florida over the flooding so
it is interesting considering Donald
Trump's going to win but we're talk
about the the news first before we get
into all the caucus stuff there's a huge
story we got the report from the
post-millennial Texas deployed armed
National Guard soldiers a doj filing
says that armed soldiers were deployed
by the National Guard to block CBP from
accessing the river this is worrisome
because we have talked about that quite
a bit on the show what happens when
Texas deploys its own I mean this is
National Guard this is military forces
against Federal officers federal agents
to prevent them from facilitating their
human smuggling and illegal immigration
operation it's getting serious we'll
talk about that we've got other big news
Tucker Carlson tweeted out American
journalist Gonzalo lra who is captured
arrested in Ukraine for reporting is
reportedly dead and is killed because of
the uh uh this is shocking uh actions by
ukrainians an American uh citizen died
in their custody so we'll talk about
that uh and of course we've got this
really great uh anti- endorsement from
Rand Paul he made a meme Netflix
presents Hillary and it's a picture of
of Nikki Haley and he launches never
Nikki so we'll talk about what's going
on with uh with all of that the blizzard
and the caucus is going to be on Monday
everyone's really really excited before
we get start of my friends head over to
twitter.com based records that's b s
records like basting a turkey but they
are based these are counterculture
musicians they produce awesome work of
course you've heard of five times August
you know Chad pra and high res they're
doing amazing work producing uh
producing music and they've helped bring
this show together sponsoring timcast
IRL here in Iowa at the uh at the caucus
would not be possible without them so
again go to Twitter follow at based
records B records and you can also go to
Bas records.com check out their music
shout outs click the link in the
description below also head over to
timcast.net
to here because of the blizzard but
we'll figure it out we'll figure it out
become a member to support the work that
we do coming to Iowa to do this special
show and this caucus event we're having
a live event with 50 or so seats semi-
toown Hall style rotating guests it is
going to be an hour longer than usual
and there won't be a members only
uncensored because we want to give more
people a chance to come in talk about
how the caucus went and so we'll have
some rotating guests but my friends it
is difficult to do these things it's
very very expensive to be able to fly
out for these primaries we're planning
another in March we're planning a show
in June with your support as members at
Tim cast.com we can do more events like
this where we can even bring you guys in
and you can hang out and ask questions
so again timcast click join us become a
member smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight talk about
this and so much more is Laura lommer
thanks for having me it's great to be
here with you in this uh blizzard if you
made it speak up closer to the mic
please it's great to be here in Iowa we
made it through the blizzard and your
car got stuck yes uh the car got stuck
twice today but thank God there's two
genders because uh pushing vehicles and
shoveling snow is for men and they did
I'm a woman I'm a woman I don't do that
well so thank you to the real alpha
males who were so kind today when they
saw us stranded in our car who pushed
the SUV right on really nice Iowa nice
Iowa nice people just a bunch of random
dudes got out and helped yeah it was
really nice so I have my crew here with
me from lumer Unleashed and then uh
there were a couple guys who just rolled
up in their pickup truck and they were
they were just so prepared you know it's
just very alpha male Behavior oh right
on you've got a bunch of videos already
out of Iowa you confronted Ronda santis
but I think and and there's some
interesting questions about uh uh I I
brought it up already Ron being here
during a state of emergency in his own
State we'll get into all that but also
you being kicked out of Nikki Haley's uh
uh event and and also Ron's event too
right yeah so I showed up to Nikki
Haley's event I've been in town since
last Friday and I've been covering all
the different events I was at Trump
rallies and I went to a v Ramis swame
event the other day and every candidate
has allowed me inside except Ronda
santis and Nikki Haley and I had tickets
for both of their events and before
Nikki's event could even begin and I'm
just standing there her staff let me in
they asked me if I wanted to volunteer
and then all of a sudden I'm surrounded
by two police officers in Iowa and
Indianola and they threatened to arrest
me and trespass me unless I left and
it's like uh hello I have a ticket so
the video went viral it has over 15
million views on X alone vas swame
commented on it because it's like you
want to be president how are you going
to be president Nikki Haley likes to
talk big talk about how oh I have my
ammunition heals and I'm going to you
know be against the dictators and
Trump's a dictat
but isn't that dictator behavior and if
you're scared of Laura lumer how are you
going to sit across the table from Putin
or
Xing and then Des santis did the same
thing I had tickets I showed up and then
you know they they removed me called the
cops and we'll play we'll play some of
these videos and we'll we'll get into
all that so thanks for hanging out we
also got Clint Russell hanging out
what's up Tim uh Clint Russell host of
liberty lockdown co-host of tower gang
don't subscribe to that and uh most
importantly co-host of the best
political show with Luke rowski we had
cernovich on today went deep dive in the
Psychedelic realm it was very
interesting it's a pleasure to be here
nice uh and we're going to be tasering
Clint once we reach 100K uh subscribers
I've been trespassed a lot too my name
is zurowski of also the best political
show.com and fun fact most people are
actually filled with 72% seed oils I'm
filled with protein Freedom caffeine
ignation sovereignty and Riz and if you
are to get the shirt on the best
political shirts.com thank you again so
much for having me this should be a
blast Ian Crossland in the house and
definitely subscribe to hour gang all
across all platforms guys are awesome
love the show thanks Laur great to see
you if you need to move that mic around
anyway twist turn it so you don't have
to move for it and just go for it yeah
before we do it because I saw Luke
staring when uh I wasn't speaking into
it right is it good should I just lean
down try to get a decent maybe we get
somebody over here to
help also Serge is pressing the buttons
I don't know if he has a microphone over
there he doesn't he's shaking his head
as do no but he's here but what he wants
to tell you is I love you everyone got
you search all right let's jump into
this first story yo this story is wild
Texas National Guard deploys armed
soldiers to block Biden's border patrol
access to the river in Eagle Pass
Governor Abbot is not harming border
patrol operations he is enhancing them
that's what they say on Thursday night
the Texas National Guard took control of
Shelby Park in the city of Eagle Pass
Texas which has been at the center of
President Joe Biden's illegal immigrant
crisis of the US Southern border
according to the Dallas Morning News the
state government has seized control of
the area and the Texas National Guard
has set up razor wire and fences to
block off the park a filing from Biden's
Department of Justice reveals the Texas
National Guard has blocked points of
entry and has deployed armed soldiers
and vehicles to block border patrol
Agents from access to the river by
bypassing through ENT bypassing through
entry points in the federal border
barrier Eagle Pass mayor Rolando selinus
told reporters that the decision was
made as part of the Republican Governor
Greg Abbott's emergency declaration and
was not something the city had requested
he added that as a result the Border
Patrol was not operating in the area
okay so this is exactly what I said I
was worried about weeks ago when we're
looking at the Biden Administration CBP
facilitating illegal immigration into
this country when you have videos of
these these uh it's the construction
equipment lifting up the razor wire that
was placed there by the state to protect
the state you've got the federal
government facilitating crimes and
unconstitutional outright it's
unconstitutional for them not to defend
the States from Invasion but they're
actually facilitating the illegal
immigration outright and then when Greg
Abbott says this is illegal the doj sues
them my fear was exactly this and what
comes next terrifies me what happens
when the Texas National Guard is
deployed with rifles with weapons to
defend the state and uphold its laws and
the Biden Administration Federal
Allegiance say you are you the ones
committing the crimes both groups point
at each other saying you're committing
crimes for now I'm hoping what happens
border patrol leaves they just leave
they can file their lawsuits and that's
the end of it but my fear is that we get
to the point where Texas National Guard
is ordered secure this area do not let
people pass plane closed federal agent
with a gun walks up and says lower your
weapon Federal this is a federal border
jurisdiction the state says back the F
off don't move and things escalate from
there I think because it's a situation
where everyone on both sides are trying
to preserve life you've got the federal
government saying these poor immigrants
we need to preserve their lives the
whereas the Texas government saying we
need to preserve the lives of our
citizens that the the law enforcement is
not going to turn on they they both want
to like deescalate and make this as
peaceful I got I got I got to stop you
right there and we'll do a fact check
the Biden Administration I believe
although it is an opinion statement I'll
respect that I will but I do think it is
fair to say the Biden Administration is
not trying to save lives yeah people
people coming on this journey die young
women are are horribly raped in huge
numbers and crossing the river is
dangerous they die children are getting
trafficked and raped they're finding
5-year-old girls with 10 samples of seen
inside of them I mean it's terrible
that's not really a pro-life position to
take and they're they're dying in the
desert so if the Biden Administration
actually said we're going to protect
these people he would go to the Mexican
Government saying we're securing our
borders we're locking it down and you
need to stop these people before they
cross into this dangerous territory
that's the argument I would make
personally I don't think that they're
helping by letting them urging them to
come across the border but I think the
state of mind that they have is toxic
compassion we can help everyone come
every you know I think that's an
excessively uh optimistic perspective on
what the bid Administration is there for
if you look at the the EU policy if you
look at the American policy over the
past 20 30 years but really aggressively
so as of late uh it seems quite clear to
me that this is actually a a plan to
flood the country with immigrants and as
a Libertarian I'm I'm rarely am I
considered a border Hawk but when you
actually look at it and you see that
this is like a a an operation that's
being ran on high I think that it would
be foolish to look the other way and say
oh no they're just the people looking
for opportunity if if it were if it were
the case as it was historically that if
you were an immigrant that got across
the border and the only thing offered to
you was perhaps a low-level job and you
had to grind your way to the top that's
a totally different incentive structure
than what we face today where these
people are offered clothes and food and
housing and everything that they could
Poss and sex changes and healthare I
mean the list goes on and on uh I don't
think that this is an accident and I
don't think it has anything to do with
uh sympathy for so I was just going to
say I don't think that we can Overlook
the fact that this is being done in an
election year as well
because what's happening is you're
having an invasion okay they're trying
to replace the population the the great
replacement is not some conspiracy
theory like the leftwing media wants it
to be they say that it's some kind of
white supremacist conspiracy theory and
as we know it's very real we are being
replaced in this country by Third World
Invaders criminal illegal alien Invaders
and unfortunately what's happening is
when these illegals are coming to places
like Texas you have Governors like
Governor Abbott who are then putting
them on buses and I I had um you know
one of my uh followers on X sent me a
video that they filmed of a bus of these
illegals with Texas plates getting
dropped off at a uh train station just
outside of Chicago why does that matter
well people may think oh it's all fun
and games you know hahaa give these
Democrats a taste of their own medicine
by shipping them to Sanctuary cities but
these are cities where they give
illegals driver's licenses and so these
people are going to have IDs and what's
going to stop them not that we really
have voter ID in this country anyway but
uh what's going to stop these people
from voting in our election but that's
not the issue vote I'm I'm not I'm not
concerned in the immediate with the idea
that illegal immigrant votes the issue
is simply by being here it gives
Democrats more congressional seats and
more electoral votes so that has to do
with the elections but so it's it's it's
that's my point is that they're doing it
on purpose and we saw the Democrat from
New York I don't know her name who said
that she's in favor of this because it's
going to you know create more of these
districts there's that school in I think
it was in New York where they said all
the students have to stay home and and
and do remote learning because they're
bringing the illegal immigrants into
that school someone posted the uh uh
political a political map of the area
and found that this area of this of of
the city or or this area of New York
voted Republican and the surrounding
area is Democrat so sure enough the area
targeted where they're shipping in a
bunch of these migrants is a red area
but what happens with illegal immigrants
in the immediate it is true that when
these people come in and then I'm
willing to bet that Joe Biden rubber
stamps some kind of amnesty executive
order on constitutionally and then makes
everyone fight about it in the Supreme
Court for years but when he does that
you may actually then see a quick
turnaround illegal immigrants voting you
will definitely see their children
voting they're very likely to vote
Democrat because they want the benefits
to themselves and their families but in
the immediate when they count population
in the census they will say oh look 10
million people live here now that's
that's going to be I mean what are we
looking at 12 congressional seats and 12
electoral votes for this state but these
people aren't even citizens but they're
getting Federal representation that'll
and that's what we are we're not a
democracy it doesn't matter if the
single individual votes if you have 10
Democrats living in an area and they put
750,000 illegal IM immigrants in it
those 10 American citizens now get one
Democrat to represent them in Congress
and that's why it's so important that we
get president Trump back in office
because president Trump has said that
he's in favor of banning Birthright
citizenship and in fact every single GOP
candidate so far including V ramas swame
has said that they're in favor of
banning Birthright citizenship which is
what happens of course when these anchor
B are born and there's only one
candidate that won't agree to it and
it's Nikki Haley because she would then
be disqualified from running for office
because she herself is an anchor baby I
don't know if you knew that Tim but
Nikki Haley's parents were not uh
citizens they were both immigrants who
had only been in this country for uh
less than three years at the time of her
birth uh which means that she
technically is not a natural-born
citizen which is a requirement to run
for president and so that's why we need
to elect a president president Donald
Trump every single candidate who wants
to be president go going forward whether
it be 2024 2028 or onward needs to
commit to Banning Birthright citizenship
we cannot be giving favors out to Anchor
babies I I think I think there's an
interesting way to look at it is I think
the argument Donald Trump has as well as
VI grami is the founding fathers did not
intend for this idea of Birthright
citizenship this idea that simply
because you were born here you are now
entitled to the full benefits of the
public cers and the National Defense etc
etc the 14th amendment was trying to
rectify the issue of slavery basically
saying these people here they're
citizens and it turned into something
that almost no other country on the
planet does I think there's like one or
two you can come here illegally have a
kid and that kid's a citizen no one in
the world does that so reasonably I
don't think the issue is that we're
Banning it I think we got to we got to
reframe it enforcing the existing
standards of the Constitution as to what
it means to be a citizen yeah if if we
you know this is the game that that
Democrats are really good at playing is
reframing the narrative that we are the
ones who want to take action when in
fact they are already took the action in
the first place in their interpretation
of how you get to be a citizen it'd be
cool if you could become a citizen by
the time you turn 18 as a kid just by
taking tests and things throughout your
your course of life because you could
easily educate someone from another
country from parents that were illegal
to be better citizens better
knowledgeable equipped people than some
people that just lounge around and drink
Mout and Dew all the
time yes I think it's important to
address that right you've got leftists
who were born in this country let's say
they're fifth or sixth generation
American
and they hate this country and want to
see it burnt to the ground and then you
have people desperately trying to come
to this country because they believe in
the American dream the only problem if
you're going to commit a crime to enter
this country I I don't think you're the
kind of person that really does believe
in this country breaking the law to come
here is the kind of it's you know if
someone comes and knocks on your door
and says I'd like to apply to be a
roommate in this building I think it's a
really great house and I can pay my rent
you say okay I believe you if someone
breaks in your house you're like I don't
trust this person actually cares about
what's going on here I think we're past
the time though of the discussion about
whether it's legal or illegal I think we
need a full immigration moratorium we we
are at full capacity here in this
country right now and I don't think that
given you know record high inflation uh
the disaster known as biomics our wide
openen border we don't need anyone else
coming into this country this is what I
advocated when and I ran on as a
candidate for congress when I ran in
Florida as well I think that we need a
10-year minimum probably a 20-year
minimum really if we're being honest
when we look at the actual number of
illegals in this country immigration
moratorium I think we need to haul
immigration altogether I'm I'm going to
I'm going to I'm going to I'm I'm going
to have to counter that Laura and say we
actually need the inversion and we need
to mass Deport I'm I'm kidding I'm I'm
in favor of both I want mass
deportations and an immigration
moratorium we're already dealing with a
a population decline if you if you were
to do that I think that you'd have to
address the the fiscal concerns and just
from a purely pragmatic uh assessment I
agree with you that that we can't afford
all of these people we certainly have
room not in the cities but there's room
in this country it's not like we have
nothing but cities everywhere the the
real issue is that from the year 2000
the national debt was just had just
broken $5 trillion as of today it sits
at 34 trillion that's that's over six
times multiplier in less than 25 years
if you if you look at the interest on
the national debt it will uh be about
150% this year of what we spend on our
National Defense our AAL defense is
comparable to the 10 biggest countries
in the world uh combined I mean we're
talking enormous sums of money so if
we're not going to get our financial
house in order then we absolutely have
to keep the the in the influx of MiG
that's one way that we can get our
financial house in order I mean just
Luke mentioned this earlier right
they're giving sex changes now and
health care to illegal aliens the price
tag to provide free healthare and just
free healthcare to illegal aliens not to
mentioned the cost of illegal uh illegal
immigration and this invasion in our
country as it stands right so if we want
to start reducing our debt and also
start being more fiscally responsible
and fiscally conservative then that's
exactly what we need we need to
militarize the United States border as
you were referencing in the beginning of
the of of the show uh we need mass
deportations and we need an immigration
moratorium I mean it's a slap in the
face to all Americans who I pay over I
mean there was a point in time I was
paying over $500 month for healthcare
and so what just you get to come across
this country why not just renounce your
United States citizenship and cross over
from Mexico illegally and then get a
free cell phone and new clothes and free
healthcare and a exchange why not let me
pull up this uh tweet we have this is a
story away from Libs of Tik Tok breaking
Chicago O'Hare Airport is shutting down
and moving their whole hotel shuttle
pickup area so it can house illegals
they're also restricting media access
and threaten that media cannot enter the
facility O'Hare has been using the
shuttle area to house illegals for
months and now there are too many why
are they trying to hide this there's a
sign at Chicago zare that reads hotel
and off airport shuttle starting
February 1st all hotel and off Airport
parking shuttles pick up in the lower
level arrival Lanes of Terminal 2 the
pickup sites is a short walk from
baggage you then have this uh o bus
shuttle Center media policy of course
saying you know contact media relations
but there have been illegal immigrants
on mattresses on the floor in O'Hare
Airport and it's not just the airport
there is huge concerns in Chicago
because they had plans to build camps
it's funny because that you know whoopy
Goldberg says Donald Trump's going to
put people in camps what do you think
they're already doing in Democrat Run
Chicago now this plan to build a camp
was postponed and delayed so what are
they doing sending them to schools yeah
look if you want to make an argument
about how we handle legal immigration I
am all for legal immigration but it has
to be done legally and there has to be a
process by which we determine how many
people can actually come into this
country maybe as Laura says the answer
is for now it's not any and maybe the
answer is it's very few or maybe
actually if it's done legally there is a
a an appropriate number for the time
being what we're seeing is the the the
economy in these in these cities is is
at serious risk you can't have camps
being propped up you have kids Young
Young Americans who can't afford to pay
their rent can't afford their groceries
but then we're finding out that some of
these migrants are getting in I think
it's in Chicago $7,000 a month in public
benefits one illegal immigrant who is
brought here the B Administration
facilitates this with human traffickers
and Smugglers puts them on
Transportation brings them to these
places around the country he been doing
it for for years now and then the
taxpayer funds to the tune of $84,000 a
year per person and young people aren't
even making that much money what would a
moratorium look like uh immigration more
because we got people that live here
that are like getting their Green Card
they've been in the process for three
years they're waiting and like in nine
months they're going to finally become
get their citizenship I guess I I mean
I'm not in office so I guess that it
would have to be whoever well let's just
say president Trump gets back into
office it would perhaps there would be
some type of system in place to you know
keep the people who had already legally
begun their process who are in the
process and then it just begins so it's
not it's not necessarily retroactive of
course if you're here illegally we would
have mass deportations but I think going
forward there definitely needs to be a
halt right a halt on visas and I mean
it's a national security threat as well
not just an issue of replacement uh we
saw this recently with all of the uh
anti-israel and pro Hamas protest in
America I mean these people are openly
supporting terrorist organizations and
and they're they're shouting death to
America death to Jews death to
Christians and then you have illegal
aliens these are not just Mexicans and
Guatemalans right these are people
coming from the Middle East coming from
Africa okay and they're sleeping inside
our airports I mean what happens if you
have some lazy uh you know low IQ TSA
agent that falls asleep or isn't paying
attention or is texting and one of these
uh Jihad us who comes across our border
illegally or somehow gets shipped to uh
the airport uh by the Biden
Administration makes it into the airport
and sets off a bomb in one of the
largest uh airports in our country
that's my absolute bigest Fe that's my
biggest fear honestly that's my biggest
fear is that one of these days one of
these illegals is going to set off a
bomb in you know Grand Central Station
or one of the airports that's my biggest
fear my mine is that groups of them are
going to actively be planning something
like we're we're at War right now this
country is at War and whether you want
to Congress didn't declare I don't care
we're at War that's the truth of it in
the Ukraine in Israel we're backing that
bombed Yemen yesterday uh okay so we're
at War you close your borders when you
go to war you don't let because the
enemies will send their people in that
you they look like citizens and they go
to the cities and like nine of them will
be on a Facebook group like okay on this
day they're already here the the you saw
the memo I I released this I broke this
story several months ago and then Daily
Caller received the official memo and
published I'm sure you can pull it up
but they've already confirmed just weeks
after October 7th that you have active
Hamas and has blah Terror cells in major
American cities uh like Atlanta like
Chicago like Washington DC New York City
and we saw them we saw their po we saw
them taking photos of themselves in uh
Time Square holding the Hamas flag so we
already know that these people are here
they're just waiting I I look at it I
look at it from a totally different
angle in that we've had the war on
terror we've had an increased powers for
the FBI the surveillance State
everything else and we've had open
borders for the past 20 plus years and
we still have had no real serious
domestic terrorism threats I mean very
very minimal so I think that it has
always been overstated that the rest of
the world is prepared to blow themselves
up to cause us harm if we were to
actually treat them with any level of
Civility and respect I don't think we
would have anything to fear and those
that were coming across our borders we
could actually stream line it make it
legal and and focus on bringing in
people that intend to be productive as
opposed to those that are looking for
handouts these are very simple answers
to the problems that we face and yet we
continue to just like pretend as if
you're going to have Trump get in there
and and remedy all this it's like the
the powers that be have already
demonstrated that they will undermine
him every step of the way unless he's
going to come in there and that he was
asked a few days ago is he interested in
retribution and he said I'm I don't have
enough time for Retribution if you don't
have time for Retribution you're not
going to fix anything you have to
prosecute fouchy you have to it's not an
option he damaged the entire planet with
his funding of that well yeah personally
I also just wanted to add that I I'm
also uh more uh afraid of all the
illegals that the CIA brings in as of
course in 2001 there was even a state
department official whistleblower that
came out on the record and said hey uh
these uh these guys that were uh you
know the 911 hijackers they were denied
visas at first until the CIA intervened
and got them into the United States
because of their deliberate interference
and them stopping government agents from
stopping the actual bad guys from coming
in so I I I think they want the bad guys
to come in I think they want age this
kind of terrorism as the FBI is warning
people saying hey you guys should watch
out as we're watching for Trump
supporters and people who go to parent
teacher School conferences I completely
agree with you and I think that they
want it because they want to blame Trump
supporters right like you just said they
want to make it seem like the biggest
threat in this country is the white
Christian male or you know the white
Trump supporter when in
reality the Deep State and all of these
federal law enforcement agencies they
benefit every single time there's a
terrorist attack like an actual
terrorist attack right cuz they get to
expand the surveillance State they get
to push for gun control and as we've
seen they have some of these uh jihadist
terrorists on their payroll look at the
case of Omar matin in Orlando Florida
the Pulse Nightclub shooter we found out
after the fact that he was not only
being monitored by the FBI but his
father was literally an FBI informant
and then he was given front row seats at
Hillary Clinton's rally when she was
campaigning for president wow so Luke's
100% spot on they they are training they
are propping up these it does even it
doesn't them to attack us it doesn't
even have to be a real terrorist attack
they can just make it seem as if there's
one and they can still roll out and
increase the the surveillance State and
the funding for the FBI which by the way
if Trump once again I'm sorry I got to
Circle back to this if Trump isn't in
interested in retribution he is once
again going to be undermined if you're
not interested in retribution against
the FBI which attempted to coup you
like more they have to do hear I didn't
hear that clip but I do know that
there's multiple you know clips from
president Trump's rallies where he says
I am your retribution and I know for a
fact from my own conversations with
President Trump as well that he 100% you
know he says it publicly so it's not
like I'm saying anything private he says
I am your retribution so I would I would
push back on that a little bit because I
don't necessarily agree with you maybe
you know there was some context missing
or perhaps he was making a sarcastic
statement at the Town Hall he
specifically said we're not he said
we're not going to have time for
Retribution because we're going to make
this country so successful and don't
forget our retribution is our success
I'm paraphrasing but that was the gist
of what he said I think they're
attempting to frame him as some sort of
fascist dictator so he's he's trying to
now reframe it as no I'm not going to go
in there looking for Retribution look I
it may be politics all I'm saying is if
he is to get that second shot yeah I
need him to actually mean it and he's
going to but I agree with you I do think
that maybe it's a messaging I don't work
for Trump you know but maybe because the
media went so crazy when he made his
little joke about oh I'm going to be a
dictator for one day they're obsessed
with it and now he talks about it at
every single campaign rally perhaps
perhaps they are messaging like you just
suggested so people don't actually think
he's going to go out and be a dictator
although I personally wouldn't mind
dictator Trump I mean if it
means if it
means if it means retribution right if
it means shutting down the FBI closing
our border if that's what dictator Trump
looks like then bring it on right but
I'm pretty sure Donald Trump isn't just
going to get back into office and you
know say oh it's business as usual with
these people that decided to completely
screw my family and screw me and jail my
supporters as political prisoners for
the last three years the man's facing
700 plus years in prison potentially if
he's if he's not upset about that to the
point that he actually like you don't
have to do anything di dictatorial you
have to enforce the laws you're
surrounded by criminals get an AG that
will prosecute these scumbag he's going
to I think it's just the media the media
is just so you know they weaponize it
and then you even have conservatives
like Nikki Haley who say oh well Trump's
going to be a dictator right while she's
actually you know using the police to
kick journalists like myself out of her
event so Donald Trump has the GOP
establishment against him he has the
Democrats against him he has the media
against him and you know it'd be great
if it's not that his campaign doesn't do
good messaging but look president Trump
has to spend hours every single day
sitting in a courtroom okay he has to
spend hours traveling right he just had
a he had a town hall in Iowa the other
night and then imagine how exhausted he
must be flying from Iowa in a snowstorm
to New York City sitting in a courtroom
with that corrupt judge Arthur and Goron
and Leticia James all day and then
flying back to wherever he flew next and
then he's coming to uh to Iowa again
it's just yeah I think he's doing the
best he can no he's going non-stop just
really quick the The Whistleblower I
mentioned was Michael springman at the
jeda consulate look into his story
because it really does reveal a lot of
the the government agents working within
uh the federal bureaucracy that that
want bad people to come in and do really
horrible things to the American people
so they did it before they were never
held accountable for it they're going to
probably do it again let's let's talk
about what's going on up here in this uh
caucus we have this tweet from Rand Paul
it's a meme made by being libertarian
and ladies and gentlemen is one of the
best memes I've ever seen it says
Netflix presents Hillary and it's a
picture of Nikki Haley and it is
masterfully done Rand Paul of course
released an
anti-s with never nii.net where uh he's
basically given his message so far
there's no heavy endorsement but he's
just saying at least not Nikki Haley I
think this meme purposefully I mean I'm
sorry um perfectly encapsulates wokeness
Netflix Netflix the Democrats and why
Nikki Haley is Nicki Hillary they nailed
it amazing J question though do you
think that Rand Paul's negative
endorsement is going to make more or
less people vote for Nikki Haley because
they say even bad press is good press I
I think the most powerful tool we have
in the culture war and even in politics
mockery yeah and so if you come out I'll
tell you this you go to the average
person and you say Nikki Haley lied
about what Russia's intentions are in in
in Eastern Europe to ex expand foreign
war and get us to spend money and I'm
telling you if she's elected we're going
to see war in the Middle East they're
going to go look if you go up to the
average person and go yo look at this
Nikki Nikki Halley Hillary they're going
to start laughing their asses off that
mockery reaches the average person
because it's the lowest common
denominator it reaches some of them
because some other people be like oh
what do you show me that crap for like
and just be like turned off by and be
like don't make fun of Don't Be Cruel
don't bring some people but the point is
making a coherent political argument
about Nikki Haley's awful foreign policy
and who she's aligned with and where she
gets their donations from is so over the
top esoteric the average person says
look I I don't know what you're talking
about dude but if you show a meme that
makes fun of Netflix wokeness and how
they do this they do these diversity
castings it makes people laugh and and
the idea why is she why is she white
though shouldn't she be black if this is
a real uh but that's the point she she
is she's the minority minity
but if it was a real Netflix special
Nikki Haley and Hillary wouldn't even be
on there right they it'd be some black
woman cuz I was told that you the only
way you get a Netflix special is if
you're you know a black black the point
n Haley is a minority maybe maybe I'm
just black pill I feel like I shouldn't
have to explain to the American people
why they shouldn't support Nikki Haley
at this point like if you if you've been
alive for the past 20 years and you've
seen what the the neocons have done and
the Neo progressives or the neoliberals
or whatever you want to class ify the
Clinton says or Obama for that matter
and I and you still haven't figured out
that like everything they've told you
has been a lie and it has just destroyed
the world destroyed your financial
well-being like I still have to explain
to you that Nikki Haley is not a good
option for president I can't even
believe this chick's running of course
unbelievable bro of course you have to
explain it the average person doesn't
know anything about foreign policy or
politics and Nikki Haley goes on stage
and the average person I'm not talking
about people who are into politics you
could be left or right the average
person who decides for some reason a
watch is going to see Nikki Haley go
Vladimir Putin is going to go after
Poland and our allies you know she does
that thing where she doesn't open her
mouth when she talks really weird but
she's going to be like he's going to
invade he's like Hitler and they go you
know I don't know who this lady is or
anything about Russia but that sounds
scary then Donald Trump will say
something in his show he'll be like it's
not correct you know Vladimir Putin is
he's he wants Crimea and they're GNA say
huh who do I believe the way the reason
why memes are so effective is that that
regular person sees Donald Trump memes
where he's riding a tank or a
velociraptor with a machine gun and they
laugh that mockery of trump and it is
but it's positive it's like look how
strong and tough he is Nikki Haley is in
is insulted as a bad Hillary Clinton who
everyone hates then when someone when
you're when you're sitting with your
friends and you turn on the debate or
whatever it is you're watching and she
says those lies about Vladimir Putin
that person goes she's she's Hillary
Clinton dude Hillary Clinton's stupid
yeah I think that memes are ammunition
in the Arsenal of persuasion and they're
not to be used on every Target like just
the illiterate just yeah they work
against certain people that they'll be
like haa yeah but other times you've got
to explain her her role on the board of
Boeing and that she's part of a war
machine and and you're correct but
everybody hates Hillary Clinton she was
one of the most despised candidates
we've ever seen and that's one of the
reasons she lost in 2016 so when you
show a picture of Nikki Haley and call
her Hillary the people who don't know
anything about it instantly understand
what that means I would say though that
we're like living in different times I I
do think that mimetic Warfare is
certainly uh you know influential uh but
but the reality is is that this isn't
about oh well I like Nikki Haley I'm
gonna vote for Nikki Haley this is about
one thing and one thing only okay and
that is getting Donald Trump and that's
why you have David plof who is uh Barack
Hussein Obama's former campaign manager
urging Democrats to show up on caucus
day in Iowa to change their registration
to Republican to vote for Nikki Haley
it's not that people actually like Nikki
Haley I'm sure that Democrats and
Republicans both recognize the fact that
she's a warmonger and a neocon who you
know has a has a board position with
Boeing and has really shady ties to
defense contractors that made her a
multi-millionaire but and she this is
this is about getting Donald Trump and
so they are still going to vote I I
think that Donald Trump's going to
overwhelmingly win the Iowa caucus but
that's why you're seeing all of Hillary
Clinton's donors people like Reed
Hoffman okay who's the second largest
Democrat Party Mega donor after George
Soros ly sign up to support Nikki Haley
they don't actually care about Nikki
Haley it's not like they really care
about her policies they just want to get
Trump whoever that is they don't care
they're I think they're even pushing for
a contingent election that's why RFK
pack just invested $15 million in uh key
key swing States because they're by
their own admission they said that their
goal is to get 15 electoral votes so
that neither Joe Biden nor Donald Trump
get 270 and then what happens uh per the
Constitution with a contingent election
is Congress then gets to decide who our
president is house delegations yes so
but Republicans out outnumber that but
with we currently have a one-seat
majority because with all these
Republicans retiring we could have
speaker hakee Jeff by March if one of
these geriatrics in Congress has a
stroke gets cancer has a heart attack
dies gets in a car accident or resigns
because they have whatever some kind of
family emergency we already know that
there's a ton of rhinos in Congress who
hate Trump and they would love to screw
Donald Trump in in an election year by
saying you know what we're just going to
retire early and uh there you go speaker
Jeff this that's why Kevin McCarthy
retired early and that's why they ousted
George santz this is a this a good point
though because one play to consider
though I don't know how likely it would
be is if a few of the Rhinos in Congress
resign giving Democrats the slim
majority by having maybe a seat gives
them the delegations and not even the
delegations but once they have Congress
they immediately vote to uh to charge
Trump with Insurrection or they simply
just pass a resoltion saying Trump is an
Insurrection I truly believe that's
their strategy I think that the rhinos
are are doing that and I wouldn't be
surprised if by March and people can
record this and there's going to be a
recording we'll see if I'm right I think
by the end of March we're going to see
another Republican resign and the
Democrats are going to take back control
of the house well if that happens I mean
I'm just curious you're you're one of
Trump's biggest supporters I'm his
biggest supporter okay his biggest
supporter I
apologize number one fan if if he is uh
you know way if he's robbed if he's
thrown off of enough State ballots that
he's whatever reason it's illegitimate
and he's kept out of office how how is
the Maga base going to react to that
well there's going to be a revolution in
this country we are voting for president
Trump regardless of whether or not his
name's on the ballot they're not going
to steal our elections from us and this
is why everybody should be appalled by
these Soros funded secretaries of States
uh like Jenna Griswald in Colorado or
Shaina Bellow in Maine who are you know
removing president Trump's name
constitutionally from the ballot and
that's my point about the contingent
election right if they are successful
like let's say the Supreme Court rules
against President Trump right he won't
get the electoral votes in those States
and it will set a precedence and allow
for other blue States or states with
Rhino or democrat secretaries of state
to remove him from the ballot under uh
section three of 14th Amendment and so
you see the possibility become more of
of reality right of of of neither
candidate getting 270 especially with
the way that RFK Jr is being so heavily
funded as an independent I think V was
saying one of the plays is it's not
about the Democratic party you know we
we've talked about oh you know the JP
Morgan guys say Joe Biden's going to
have a medical issue in March he's going
to drop out and then we speculate it was
gonna be Newsome is it gonna be Michelle
Obama when it's been Nikki Haley the
whole time they they V saying they're
not going that route they're going from
within the party they're propping up
Nikki Haley who is very obviously like
you you put her next to Hillary Clinton
and take the same talking points same
thing Russia Russia Russia all this
foreign foreign policy guard keeps hot
sauce in her purse right see there you
go and uh but the point is when they're
taking Trump off the ballot people say
who cares if Trump's off the ballot in
Colorado Colorado is a blue State yes
but it's the primary ballot now he's
back on of course but if California does
it Trump needs to win the California GOP
Primary it's not about the general
election they want to create a situation
in which Nikki Haley some somehow wins
the nomination to give them some kind of
legitimacy against Trump yeah I think
Trump will run as independent regardless
but then they split the vote and it's
like you said contingent election
interesting I I'm very nervous because
even if Say Say by some miracle Trump
beats all the all the charges and he's
actually on the ballots and he wins the
election and he gets into power and the
and the Deep State doesn't take him out
that's a lot of ifs all right but he
gets through all those ifs and he and he
and he finally gets in there I still
think we're looking at the potential for
a revolution in this country just
because I think that the the media and
the Deep state will activate the left in
this country in a way that's
extraordinarily dangerous maybe we need
one honestly I mean maybe we need one no
I don't want to live through that no the
country is a reevolution I mean I'm just
saying that our country okay our country
was born in a revolution and so maybe in
order to take our country back we're
going to need a revolution I'm not
calling for a civil war I'm not inciting
violence but I am saying that you know
people get so scared with the words oh
Revolution and you know they they like
to say that Trump supporters are
insurrectionists weren't our founding
fathers technically speaking
insurrectionists if they lost what if
they lost yeah they were for sure
terrorists they were considered but but
hold on re Revolution doesn't always
mean violence exactly that's my point I
think but historically it typically is
related to it because the people in
power won't I think of it a lot as a
revolution of the mind I've been
thinking of it since but that's what Mao
called the the cultural revolution in
China too they were like it's a
revolution of the mind and like so if
we're going to do that which we kind of
are with shows like this we've got to be
really intricate about how we do it
revolution of Truth a revolution of
Truth TR but but let's let's clarify
because I like the founding father's
vision for this country I like the
Constitution I think it's brilliant I
really do think people should study the
found like read the Constitution read
the how the branches of government are
meant to operate read the founding
father's quotes and how they were coming
up with this system you've got they were
like should we have a monarchy no that's
crazy because of this problem should we
have a direct democracy no because of
this problem what about a Council of
Elders no this hey what about all three
of them and they all kind of argue with
each other at once it's like maybe
that's the best way to do it I don't
think it's a revolution we want I think
it's a reignition I think it's a um a
reaffirmation or more importantly a
cleansing or accountability for too long
people in this country have grown
complacent sitting by and letting
corrupt people exploit the system
Congress is plagued with corruption we
can see it in their stock trading deals
all we need to do is we don't we don't
want to Revolution in the sense of the
classical sense of changing this country
no we want to restore it which means a
restoration restoration is a good way to
put yeah I'm all for it I mean this is
why this is the only reason that I I
even consider the potential of a trump
second term being a positive is if he
has actually recognized that it's not
and he always says this so he has to
have recognized it he always says
they're not after they're not after me
they're after you I'm just standing in
the way you know and it's like all right
Trump you're you're not wrong but like
if that's the case well then do what's
necessary to defend the people he going
to but listen he's going to there's
there's a mistake made by the Democrats
and sometimes even by the right in the
assumption that Donald Trump is Maga
Donald Trump is a symptom of and an
amalgamation of the anger that many
Americans felt watching this corruption
for so long and Donald Trump came and as
a bull charging through the doors he
said we're going to have this guy but
what they don't understand is that I
Bannon was alluding to this Trump's the
moderate Trump is actually the moderate
working with you guys he really is
because if if if if there isn't a a
restoration the next person to step up I
mean you take a look at how Donald Trump
is approaching this election saying
we're not going to have time for
Retribution our success will be our
retribution I I I agree with the idea
that I I certainly think Trump Wants
Revenge but I do think he's concerned
about being portrayed as an
authoritarian dictator and he's trying
to walk it he's trying to play it down a
little bit to win votes but you look at
V ramaswami getting up there and saying
we're going to dismantle the ATF we're
going to dismantle the FBI we're going
to break these things apart he's coming
out
substantially way more direct in what
needs to be done in this country if
Donald Trump is not the candidate this
time around the next person we may get
who may be vake is going to be much much
more direct well and I don't think the
president Trump has a problem with being
direct but let's be honest VI's not
going to win okay and so I like VI I do
but but when you're not going to win and
you don't have the media necessarily I
mean let's be honest the media is
ignoring VI ramaswami I think it's wrong
you see the way that they they
disinvited him and changed ignored him
too of the daily wire exactly and and
I'm not a fan of Ben Shapiro I like the
V Ras swame I'm supporting Trump but you
can you can be more direct not saying
that Trump is not or not saying that
Trump is withholding but vake can he has
a liberty to I guess be a little bit
more Wild on the campaign Trail because
the reality is he's not going to win I'm
pretty sure he knows he's not going to
win and I think that he would be great
for 2028 as long as he stays in his
place and he doesn't you know disrespect
president Trump and I say stay in his
place because America First is a
movement and I think that President
Trump is the leader of the America first
movement and obviously president Trump's
not going to be around forever and so we
need someone to carry on that Legacy but
you don't get to carry on the Legacy by
being disrespectful like all these other
candidates have like Ronda santis okay
the V ramas swame is running the
campaign that Ronda Santa should have
run yep agreed I I think the issue for V
it's not even about being disrespectful
to Trump because I think think is he's a
trump supporter yeah he is it's it's I'm
talking about that's he's been able to
walk this fine line of technically
running against Donald Trump but also
not pissing off the magga base and so if
he watches If he if he stays in his
place and he doesn't get too hotti in
the sense that he doesn't start
supporting weaponized government and I
don't think that he will I think vras
swame will walk into the White House in
2028 he he is he is running the campaign
Ron should have run yeah VI I I I told
this to aake uh the second time we
talked we we had a one-on-one
conversation on the culture War podcast
and I said you're not going to win okay
I mean and he's like well we'll see
we'll see I'm like come on like I know
he can't say it I know he has to do his
best and he has to try that's what
anyone who wants to prove themselves in
politic politics has to do and so I can
respect it and I can also respect why he
can't just come out and be like guys I
get it yeah and and he's trying to build
up his bonafides right now one of his
plays which is absolutely just expressed
in great detail on the show we had on on
Wednesday was he believes
they the Deep state will stop at nothing
to remove Trump and yeah I I'll
paraphrase everything he said he's he's
a safety net uh we we we would prefer
Donald Trump I don't know about you guys
I would prefer Donald Trump in fact I
got in a perfect world uh VI VP Trump
finishes out his last term VI comes in
next we thought that was going to be Ron
it's not in the event God in the in the
in the event that the worst happens to
Trump and whatever that may be I don't
know I'm not suggesting anything but
let's just say for some reason Trump is
gone I very very grateful that it will
not just be handed to Nikki Nikki
Hillary no and I'm grateful that and I
had V on my show uh last week and you
know he said exactly that right he said
that he recognizes that he I don't you
could watch the clip and see what he
said word for word on my show Lumar
unleash but it was like I'm in this race
to make sure that it's not just a
two-person race between Nikki Haley and
Joe Biden so he's essentially running a
campaign to be a safety net for
president Trump but we already know that
the see what I don't like is I don't
like all of the theories right that are
pushed by right wiers like oh yeah
Tucker's going to be VP oh V's going to
be VP no Tucker already said he's not
going to be VP V already said he's not
interested in being VP and I think that
conservatives love being distracted I've
noticed this about right-wingers right
and I'm a registered Republican so I
could vote in Florida a closed primary
state for president Trump but I hate the
Republican party I hate the Democrat
Party I hate both political parties
right and there you just have you just
notice like how easily Republicans are
distracted right it's like shiny object
over here shiny any object over there
they can't focus on on these court cases
they can't seem to focus what's in front
of their eyes and it's like every little
clickbait uh headline about who's going
to be VP who's going to be director of
FBI catches everybody off guard we're
we're arguing about calendars meanwhile
the other side is literally imprisoning
journalists for talking about issues I I
also just want to add a couple couple
things this election cycle is going to
be crazy I I I I think it's it's fair to
say that we don't know what the
outcome's going to be who knows there
could be a scenario there could be a
situation where it could be Vivic or it
could be somebody else or it could be
another Dark Horse we're still very
early on here and even though they say
publicly they don't want to be the VP
politicians always say they don't want
to be the VP but then usually get
selected to be the VP as well this is an
election there's politicians there's a
lot of liars there's a lot of people
saying one thing and really mean another
thing and with this crazy election cycle
things are going to get wild and
absolutely unpredictable so anything and
everything could happen and probably
will I don't I I think the the choice
for VP is clearly Tucker Carlson uh we
we were on the stage with him at tpusa
and everybody was laughing being like
Tucker like you're the guy but you know
Tucker's point was just because he's
good at media and he's he's Insight
doesn't mean he knows how government
operates and so that doesn't so you
actually think he's gonna be VP no oh I
was gonna say no because the Trump
campaign and I'll say this I do not work
for president Trump but I'm pretty sure
the Trump campaign is starting to get
really pissed off with everybody
insinuating who's going to be you know
VP who's going to be hired for what
position and they've literally issued
three statements now and their last
statement said that if people keep doing
it they're going to start naming names
and in terms of like calling people out
because they're they're tired of it's a
distraction right like this is done
intentionally to distract people from
the issues at hand the ballot cases the
weaponization of government okay the way
that they're trying to undermine our
elections uh by keeping Donald Trump
tied up in court and so unless it comes
out of Donald Trump's mouth or an
official statement from the campaign
people should stop even talking about
even Tu Tucker's point is he doesn't
want to be VP stop saying it he
said said the same thing and right
Tucker is saying I'm not a government
guy Trump needs a government person and
so there's there's plenty of other
options and that'll be up to them for
them to decide but uh I I want to pull
up this clip you have of uh uh of Ronda
santis we have this tweet from Laura
lomer he got lered Ronda santis gets
lered inside his hotel this is the this
is the image that's going viral it's
being MD Ronda sandz looking shocked as
of course Laur lomer uh confronts him
but there's a really interesting point
brought up in your confrontation a
question that was uh asked by you and
another individual Ron he looks scared
to death already he he really does and
that's guy great screenshot Ronda santis
issued a state of emergency in Florida
after a major storm hit there's flooding
two days ago two days ago and uh I
didn't know that you know I'm here it's
two days ago we are in Iowa right now
during what they call a blizzard of the
decade a once in a decade blizzard the
bus businesses didn't open today we went
to like Starbucks was closed we were
able to get some coffee unfortunately we
didn't have any Casper here with us but
we went we tried going to a Tha food
restaurant closed next door piz shop
closed there's a few places that are
still open we went to a hotel restaurant
to find food to get lunch because hotels
are open Uber Eats delayed by 30 minutes
oh jeez it's crazy now here's the point
and I'm banned on Uber Eats how do you
think I feel so here's here here here's
when I watched this clip of you I heard
that and I went whoa wait really and I
googled I checked out the state of
emergency Ronda santis is the governor
of Florida his State needs him and
instead of being there he is in Iowa a
place right now where let's be honest
the storm has everything shut down he
doesn't need to be here he can campaign
he can be in Florida and then he can he
can remotely do what he needs to do but
it is shocking to me that a time where
the city is paralyzed by this blizzard
he opted to be in Iowa during their
blizzard instead of Florida it's even
worse than that so he flew to Florida I
think it's uh today's what the 12th so I
think it was the 9th if you check the
day the screenshot on the ninth he flies
9th of the 10th flies to Tallahassee
from Iowa to give his State of the State
address stays for a couple hours
declares a state of emergency while he's
there and then immediately gets on a
plane back to Iowa so you fly to give a
State of the State and he's getting
booed by legislators and lawmakers who
are there in attendance because uh the
town of Tallahassee had been affected by
the storms okay 49 out of 67 of
Florida's counties were affected
by the storms and the tornadoes and
Rhonda santz is polling at 14% in Iowa
5% in New Hampshire they stopped all ad
spending in New Hampshire and it's like
come on you wasted $300 million of
everyone's money around
pretending like you're going to be
president of the United States you're an
absentee Governor cut it out get back to
Florida and do your damn job I'm I'm I'm
I'm I'm sorry I'm just this one really
really pissed me off because I have I
have said I liked him policy-wise he
shouldn't have been running his
campaigns run poorly but his State needs
him right now and and and look I know
that the St people are going to come to
me and say Donald Trump did this Donald
Trump did that he went vacation fine by
all means like criticizing any other of
these politicians I will say yes to you
when I see Ronda santis do what you just
described La flying fly out and he's in
a state that is undergoing a he's he's
in De Mo there's a blizzard and he's
here instead of his home state I'm just
like look aside from the fact it was the
wrong move morally he also just lost a
tremendous opportunity to prove he is
the good leader by standing with Florida
and saying to all the people of Iowa
know this as your president I will never
abandon you like I will not abandon the
people of
my the first time done this though and
the last thing I want to say is he had
an opportunity to actually use this as a
secondary method of maybe this is how he
bows out gracefully by saying I will not
be at the Iowa caucus because my state
needs me I won't abandon them instead
I'm looking at his face this scared face
and I'm like here's a guy who abandoned
his State during a state of emergency to
to be third or fourth place like you
just pointed out he's losing he's spent
all this money I'm like this is abject
campaign failure in every possible way
this is you don't Governors don't run
are not supposed to be able to run for
president they've got to step down from
governance in order to do that because
the campaign's so demanding so what did
he do to change that rule so I said that
to him too if you want to play the video
uh we can play it and talk about it or
talk about it and then play it whatever
you want to do Tim but uh essentially
and I talked about this when I was on
your show um a couple months ago right
when I debated the Aging lesbian um Bill
Mitchell shout out to Bill Bill Mitchell
and I want to clarify too he's the one
who said that and he and and funny guy
he he was in the joke he he rolled with
the punches but that was him who said
that he said it you know can can we play
this clip play I'll explain it yeah all
right uh that was today do we have uh do
we have I don't think we have audio
though gotta get audio yeah no audio
givee givee gime all right never mind
nope that's lur on the left well we can
wait till until you get audio want to
wait uh I I think we just got to click
the we we'll start it over start it over
start it over then so uh let's see here
um so this is today want a full
screen I'm
recording okay thank you hey Governor
thank when are you going to drop out
don't you think you've already wasted
enough of people's money $300
million Governor Des santis why do you
have a bubble wrapped campaign Ron
pretending to get a drink are you going
to be endorsing president Trump when you
drop out the night of the Iowa caucus or
hopefully shortly
after an absentee governor who changed
the law in Florida so that you could run
for
president answer a question Ron I
thought you were never backed down Never
Back Down Ron whatever happened to that
don't CR charges against
you there's a state of emergency in your
state why aren't you there there's state
of emergency in the State of Florida
that you declared into abandoned
Floridian why you hitting me why are you
hitting
me you want to be Governor if it wasn't
for president Trump you betrayed
president Trump you betrayed the people
of Florida and you're going to lose 14%
in Iowa 5% in Hampshire
[Laughter]
Ron you're a nightmare you can
see it's
always STIs no it gets worse everybody
so I'm here in front of the hotel in
West Mo Iowa and RNE s just got LED he
looked petrified honestly I think that
his soul left his body when he saw me
and he's such a coward whatever happened
to Never Back Down Right Never back down
he ran into the hotel convenience Lobby
you know where they sell the little
snacks and the waters and the tampons
and things like that let's just I want
to I want you're here you can tell us
exactly no it's just 30 more seconds
just play it when you said absentee
Governor's eyes ran you want to piss off
low took the elevator up to the nth
floor to run away from me this is a guy
who is too scared to face an independent
journalist Laura Limer he's running a
bubble wrapped insulated campaign
campaign doesn't want to talk to the
people and he runs away he's going to
lose president Trump is going to kick
his ass in Iowa on Monday January 15th
and that's it for Ron you killed your
political career Ron and I hope you're
happy you just got lumed
and now you know what the weather was
like in Iowa today sideways blowing sow
oh and it got crazier uh uh a few hours
ago it was just like total white out
when you said absentee Governor his
that's when his eyes went screenshot and
he was like realized what he was doing
being away from Florida like it's it's
you know what really really shocked me
call I call him I call him you know
why I call him Florida's absentee
Governor I'm not calling him gay right
oh I see I'm saying it's Florida's
absent yeah it's an acronym look look
Florida
may I say that the right way Florida's
absente governor that's I was uh I'm I'm
disheartened I'm like here's this guy
that a uh two years ago just just about
not even two years ago I was hanging out
to daily wire crew saying I think he
might be the guy he's got the young
energy he's got the Trump stuff behind
him Trump hadn't announced or anything
like that we don't know what he was
doing Ronda santis was the lead in the
betting markets across the board he was
favored to win he's now below Nikki
Haley so and I'm just I'm s look like
we've consistently said ofas swame too
in New Hampshire I mean he's actually in
fifth place in New Hampshire we we've or
was until Chris Chrissy dropped out yeah
we've talked about how
he's oh he's great on policy he's done a
good job in Florida and there's a lot of
things he's done that's that's that that
we can say are good but this is a hell
of a way to end your political career to
leave your state during an emergency to
campaign where you're losing getting
gloomed well see the well maybe he's
trying to do a retribution Arc because
what better way to to fail and then uh
try to make your way out of this hole
that you dug yourself in I mean there's
that possibility well the decision that
he made to only go with corporate media
and to avoid all alt media the basically
as you someone said earlier like he
should have done exactly what fa's done
if he if he had an ounce of Charisma if
he wasn't so deep on the Spectrum he
could actually just engage with all of
the people that are like churning the
culture out in this country but instead
he's avoided us he's now he's getting
lumed and looks like he his pants
when she approached him it's like it's
just devastating to watch I moved to
Florida because of this guy I I'm a
California Refugee I appreciate what he
did as Governor but his campaign has
been disastrous on a on a level that I I
can't even really fathom it's it's it's
not just Ron it's also Nikki okay so
there's arguments to be made for you
know if you're someone like Ronda santis
don't engage if say like Laura is coming
at com coming coming at you today though
and you can't okay this is the thing you
can't go around calling your pack Never
back down I mean it's so ridiculous
Never back down right just like I said
in the video oh Never Back Down except
with Laura lmer right he won't even do a
spaces
with like he's so w that because he
doesn't like us you can't go around
saying that you're a fighter and Say
Never back down and then run he had
every single confrontation I'm convinced
to Stage he had climate protesters today
he had climate protesters today at his
event in or yesterday in ases and he
goes you're being rude this is my time
not yours be quiet be quiet I mean he
just acts like a toddler first of all
every time he speaks and secondly he
likes to talk like he's so tough and
even worse you could pull up the Tweet
10 minutes after he got lored he posted
a tweet on pull it up so people can see
he posted a tweet on his uh Ronda santis
account that said something like oh I'll
never run away from anything except me
except me no no it's it's it's i' say
mostly you but did you know that uh
Ronda San's campaign has banned his uh
people from appearing on Tim cast IRL
yeah for a while now we talked about
that last time I was on it's crazy but
this is what makes V's campaign so so
impressive I I I have never seen anyone
that's willing to talk to he's done my
show with Luke he's done my show solo
he's done Dave Smith he's done IRL
he's he's done oh right right right no
no I'm say V he will talk to anybody and
and it's totally unscripted he he will
take all comers people that are
detractors people that don't like him he
is just he is like it's just purely
through he's inviting protesters outside
who are protesting his event to come
inside start
out to individuals like who are willing
to criticism who who are willing to
controversy and have hard difficult
conversations that's what wins elections
and that's what dtis is not doing he
should be doing this show he should be
arguing he should be making his stand
and he's not doing any of that he does I
mean no contentious interviews are you
kidding me you're running a campaign
here talk to the people who of course
represent the people the most The
Independent Media the people on the
ground the people who represent the
people more than the corporate media
that that you keep giving exclusive
interviews to it's a shame that's why I
said when he was in there I said Ron why
are you running a bubble wrap insulated
campaign because Nikki Haley is too they
want to wrap these people in bubble wrap
to protect them because everything has
to be scripted every little interaction
Nikki Haley has town halls and now she
doesn't even take Town Hall questions
anymore whereas V raas swame I was at
his uh his um uh press conference at the
Iowa capital the other day and he's
given a talk about no eminent domain for
private gain and this you lady from
Cambodia starts screeching at the top of
her lungs and he says how about this
let's make a deal I'm going to give you
the microphone for 60 seconds and you're
going to make your case and then I'm
going to tell you why you're wrong and
you know I've never seen anything like
it it's honestly I'm a trump supporter
and I'm voting for Trump no one's ever
going to change my mind but it is so
impressive it is so impressive to see
the way that V communicates with
opposition here's the big takeaway too
and I hope people have have taken note
of this is that because Nikki Haley and
DeSantis took corporate donors it made
it impossible for them to do the media
circuit that V has done because if they
say the things that would be popular in
those audiences their donors are going
to be pissed so they can't do it they've
basically taken the money so they can
buy the ads and they're just going to
have their influen was try and set the
narrative as to who they are and how
they'll how they'll govern and set their
policies from the highest interest who
paid for them just like we saw with
Rhonda Santos's flip-flop on Ukraine
which was the first sign that that I saw
especially after the the Tucker Carlson
interview where he he he bowed down he
cowed down to the corporate media but
but more importantly he took special
interest money and then flipped his own
policiy which is something that that I
don't want to see from my political uh
you know
leader I remember back when Luke was
like Ron's doing a great job in Florida
he was he was head of the PO he did an
incredible job in Florida he did an
incredible job with with the sickness he
did an incredible job when it came to uh
people's bodily autonomy he did an
incredible job especially when it came
to countering all this nonsense when the
corporate media was telling everyone
that there was going to be a genocide in
Florida because of his Co policies and
you think that but honestly as somebody
you now for my understanding right like
you moved to Florida so absolutely yeah
so for people who saw it from the
outside it was all a farce okay Ronda
santis is a Manchurian Candidate and as
we know Fox News has been grooming him
for years now to be this opposition
candidate to Donald Trump his covid
record was no different than the record
of some of these Democrats it's just the
media lied Li about it I was running for
congress in 2020 in Palm Beach County
and I was not able to knock on doors
because there were lockdown orders and
you were threatened with arrest in uh
Palm Beach County for walking on the
beach there were parents that got
arrested uh there were the first time a
pastor has ever been arrested and over
120 years in the United States happen in
Tampa Florida and he's now I believe
supporting uh president Trump I'm
telling you right now people were lied
to about Ronda Santos's record he pushed
the vaccine he's on video telling
everybody that the vaccines have a 99% %
Effectiveness rate and I know people are
going to say well how can you be a
hypocrite Trump pushed the vaccine too
Trump pushing the V never fored anybody
to get it but it's a matter of choice I
don't agree with it I'm not vaccinated I
will never take the vaccine I refuse to
why are we trying to adjudicate
something four years ago when right now
just making the point that he's not a
good governor and people need to stop
saying that he had a great record on Co
because it's a lie you can read his own
executive orders that say I'm locking
down the beaches I'm locking down the
restaurants he's a liar he a candate I
can say right now my point when I when I
was bringing this up to about Luke's
prior support is that here's a guy who
is losing he's losing badly and he
decided to abandon his State during a
state of emergency everything else out
the window you you can come and tell me
that the dude saved a baby from that was
rushing down a river and he jumped in
and then you tell me that he left his
State during a state of emergency to try
and win a race he was badly losing and
I'm like he is a bad leader that's it
everything else is gone that one was
like just I still think I I we need an
acknowledgement from from from Donald
about what happened to operation warps
speed there's been a lot of Americans
that that have been injured one of them
was here at the I'm so sick of talking
about
this it's still a major issue because
let's just say he he comes into office
the CIA Peter daac Echo Health Alliance
all they have to do is restart and do
whatever they did again be be because
there there isn't there isn't a
conversation about hey I learned my
lesson hey there's some mistake should
have done something better absolutely
not absolutely not when still he's
telling people to to get boosted just a
few freaking months ago the policies and
and it's funny when I see Journal like
these these Centrist type journalists
who don't like Donald Trump actually
arguing with with people over this and
they they're putting things like man I
really don't like Trump but operation
warp speed was Therapeutics and vaccines
by choice it was never forcing people to
get Medical Treatments and when that
happened he came out and said they
shouldn't be doing this and now years
later I'm I'm I'm just like dude it's
four years later okay I get it we we
should never forget how bad those things
were but it's weird to me that we look
at these Blue State Governors who
literally murdered people in New York
and it's like but Donald Trump it it
funded scientific rech just say
something can I just say go back it goes
back to the concept of Revolution look I
understand people have to provide for
their families and so I'm not trying to
sound like a cold-hearted with
what I'm about to say but everybody has
choices everybody has free will and I'm
really sick and tired of listening to
people say things like oh I would have
lost my job or oh well you know it would
have been fired you either stand for you
either stand for something or you fall
for everything and if more people in
this country would have stood up and
taken to the streets and fought back
against these tyrannical lockdowns
president Trump never forced the vaccine
on anyone president Trump never forced
extended lockdowns president Trump never
forced people to wear masks people
accept people allowed their children to
against lockdowns Trump attacked Sweden
who decided not to lock down that's a
fact I still want an acknowledgement of
it and because we don't have an
acknowledgement of it because because
Trump still believes that the the
vaccine millions of hundreds of millions
of lives take scenario could again
unfold okay I'll tell I'll tell you why
I'm done with this because the
anti-trump people say Trump did the
exact same thing Ron Des santis did but
Trump was wrong when he did and then the
T people are like Des santis did the
same thing that Trump did but was right
when he I'm like dude in the beginning
of Co and the lockdowns Donald Trump
said 15 days saw the spread and we were
all not everybody but a lot of people
were like okay well we don't know what's
going on and now that we have hindsight
you have people being like Ron was
correct no Trump was correct no Ron dude
I don't think we need to adjudicate four
what happened four years ago now that we
have hindsight and we can talk about it
today it's not fair now what's going to
happen
is everyone's going to just keep going
back to four years four years ago four
years ago four years ago I'm I'm asking
I'm asking what happens next year can we
get Pro can we get an AG that actually
looks in the cre funding all
that arrest fou matter all I'm trying to
say is that you know people have their
opinions very strong opinions about
covid I'm you know the biggest Trump
supporter there is and I never took the
vaccine never got boosted never will I
me I'm a proud antivaxer but did get
boosted I just want to see more personal
I'm losing my mind
like up yeah dud this is what I
felt like at the Zero Hedge debate by
the way holy let's just not
talk over each other had this debate
7,000 times and I'm I'm sorry I'm losing
my mind I am so over people like
Trump was bad because Trump did a thing
age with you we we did not know what was
happening four years ago and now we are
four years on with mass illegal
immigration 10,000 people per day and
you're talking about a vaccine program
for four years
ago here we go again the comments were
made a couple weeks ago by by Donald
Trump about Donald Trump came out and
said it should be your choice yes that's
my point we're done he said you should
get you guys think that the reason why
we talk about okay okay let's let's
solve this talk to a doctor talk to a
doctor don't take advice from Donald
Trump on medical practices talk to your
doctor if you don't trust your doctor
find a doctor you trust but I remember
when Donald Trump was at a rally and he
said oh I love the vaccine they booed
him and he goes yes but it's your choice
I don't understand why you're conflating
Donald Trump saying he I I invested in
medical in in medical research you can
choose it and now you're like it's
Trump's fault he allowed the American
people to be guinea pigs he allowed to
get away never be held responsible for
the the Amic people there are so many
people that were injured there were so
many people that were hurt and they
deserve justice and they deserve to
derang and those people their votes are
going to matter here and and right and
and this is Trump derangement
person Tim you agree with me on this
it's about personal accountability I'm
not trying to redate this issue I I
agree with you Tim I'm taking your
position my point is that people need to
stop bitching about it because the
reality is is you decide what goes
inside your own body and nobody put a
gun to your head and said they're going
to kill you if you don't take this
vaccine said they'll kick you out milary
they'll if more people would have stood
up again it's I really firmly believe
it's about personal accountability
talking you're talking to
peopleo Gretchen Whitmer wolf uh who is
New Jersey it's been so long uh Nome of
course uh the gold guy was Democrat
Governors mandating all of these things
all all of it the elderly people who
died
and and and I I want to stress too I do
think it's important that we talk about
these things because holy crap I can't
believe everything that happened that
being said this this debate comes down
to Trump derangement syndrome and to
santis derangement syndrome and I'm just
like where are we today where we are
today is we are in Iowa during a massive
blizzard we have questions about what
the plans are for the future of this
country we might be stuck with it Donald
Trump said oh yeah God willing no but
it's good I think we're having a good
time I'm I everyone's get heated you got
to get passionate about conversations
it's fine it's good and and so what the
concern right now is Donald Trump says
retribution or no retribution legitimate
questions and I think we've actually
worked that through maybe he's just
saying that because he's trying to
appear more moderate or maybe he's
backing down who knows but I think he's
my personal opinion is trying to appear
more moderate Ronda santz flew to
Florida declared a state state of
emergency I'm super offended by that me
too I'm I don't see the debate between
Trump and disantis on Co when the debate
is Democrats versus Republicans on Co
and I don't know why we're having a GOP
debate over who got it more wrong than
the person when Democrats murdered
people we we shouldn't be having this
debate because desantis's career is dead
so it doesn't it doesn't matter but but
what does matter is is if Trump who is
the favorite what he's going to do
moving forward and which is why I'm not
trying to litigate the past I'm trying
to prosecute those responsible for it I
think that if you if you expect us to
have a free country moving forward you
you absolutely have to investigate the
people that are responsible for the
greatest Calamity in my if not human
history we're talking T of millions of L
lives we can't just brush that over we
can't and I don't think Donald Trump is
going to he said it numerous times and
if you you know if you uh study Donald
Trump like I have and you look at some
of his previous statements from over the
years Donald Trump is all about
retribution and revenge he always says I
love getting even it's it's from his uh
interview with I believe in the 1970s
with uh Charlie Rose he said I love
getting even and Charlie goes uh oh you
do really he goes yes I love getting
even Trump is all about getting even and
getting getting not I wouldn't say like
necessarily Revenge but retribution on
people that do wrongs against the
American people and and our country and
that's why he's always saying I am your
retribution and and and let's and let's
say uh uh he changed his mind my my my
position you know it's it's funny
because you get these disantis fans on
Twitter being like you're in the Trump
cult I'm like dude my position is Trump
is not the best president uh uh he's not
the president we dream of he's the best
we have who are you gonna vote for Vi
now I will say this in my lifetime in my
lifetime Donald Trump is the best
president this country has had in my
lifetime I agree and and you you take a
look at Foreign Wars I love seeing the
Libertarians be like under Trump no new
Wars under Biden three new Wars already
with us involvement not to mention the
reignition of Middle Eastern conflict
that the that Biden has sent people into
and now I'm sitting here giving fire
emojis to rashita T when she called out
Biden for his unconstitutional bombing
of Yen without Congressional approval
I'm like rishid is completely correct
yep so who am I going to vote for I'm
I'm not I'm never the person who says
the lesser of two evils if you if you
think Donald Trump is is a degree of
evil don't vote for him but I look at
Donald Trump and I'm like foreign policy
is A+ Abraham Accords negotiating with
North Korea no new Wars withdraw from
the Middle East I I see those as the key
issues for me V I agree but realism V is
not in the experienced position he does
not have the same connections and he is
not media positioned to actually win so
as much as I would say I'd love of aake
presidency it is Trump's time right now
for this you're taking the pragmatic
approach and that's totally totally
reasonable but I see Trump as a net
positive I I'm not I'm not even saying
that he can't be he he has the potential
to be a great president like he was was
okay if it weren't for 2020 he would
have been a good president last go
around but he has the potential to be a
great president but the only way he can
actually fulfill on that promise is to
actually go after all of the corruption
in the deep sea and hey and you know
what maybe or maybe not in terms of
foreign policy what what I will say is
whether or not Trump gets retribution
does not change the fact that he has my
vote okay well he can be I'm not going
to vote for Ronda Sanz that's laughable
Nikki Haley is offensive to suggest I
would vote for
Swami I would vote for in the instance
Trump was not available do you think
that people don't criticize Trump's
campaigning this time around they like
we do with Ron and Nikki and VI I mean
we give VI a lot of positive criticism
but we criticize it and is because he's
the incumbent because Trump is the
incumbent I I had a very interesting
conversation with Mike cernovich um o
over lunch after after the show and I I
you know it's going to be it's going to
be hard to sise the conversation that we
had here but we essentially said hey
Holden uh you know even our guys feet to
the fire is absolutely important because
it actually implements policies that
that puts us in the right direction so I
think we do need to be critical of
anything and and and everyone that's
even in our own party because then we
could help kind of align this country to
move forward in a way where there's no
future mistakes made and I think that's
critically important uh constructive
criticism is really important the facts
do matter about this particular case and
there were some mistakes made they
should be addressed they haven't and
this is why this is an issue of concern
to make sure that we don't repeat repeat
these mistakes again because very easily
the people in charge could just redo the
same situation in 2020 and we'll be in
trouble again exactly and this this is
why it would it would assuage so much of
my fears if he were to have aake in
there uh as VP because I strongly
believe after talking to V for hours now
that he is he is more than capable of
actually going after Dei ESG the Deep
State more broadly fouchy all of it he
he really does have that capacity and I
know that Trump is under the gun and
he's dealing with tons of litigation and
all sorts of you know undermining of his
everything so it would be nice if he
could have someone who's as as hard
charging as V I've never seen anyone
more energetic in politics no one is
perfect but we shouldn't be idolizing
fanty though V has already said this is
what I was talking about before about
why waste time talking about things that
we already know are not going to be
reality I agree that vake is you know
the next the next uh the next best
option I'm supporting president Trump
and I'm voting for Trump I don't care
what happens in 2024 I will write
president Trump's name in Sharpie across
the ballot even if they take him off the
ballot I know you will
but with v he he already has said
publicly that he doesn't want to be VP
but that doesn't mean that he won't take
yeah but politicians say that all the
time and then they usually sometimes
become VP it's like if you're running a
race you don't say I'm running to get
the silver medal you say I'm going to
get gold I'm going to get I think it' be
great to see V uh in some type of
cabinet position in president Trump's
White House and I think that you know
aside from Maybe Carrie Lake I don't
know of anybody else in the Republican
Party who is who is as an effective as a
communicator and is as solid on the
issues as V gramas swame you have Trump
you have V gramas swame and you have car
Lake I'm not impressed by anybody else R
and Ron should have recognized the the
reality of when it is your time and what
that means it doesn't mean that by by
nature of what year it is it's your turn
or not your turn Hillary Clinton thought
it was her time but the reality was
she's disliked it's not and with all du
respect of aake I think I think he the
hardest working guy in politics but it's
not his time why because the Trump base
has an opportunity to give Donald Trump
his second term that they wanted to see
and they like VI but they're like VI you
have a lot of time in front of you you
have a whole career in front of you next
time is good for you that was Ron's
option that was Ron's path yeah it was
the Trump to S his ticket everyone was
excited for and then Ron basically was
like well I'm gonna come out and just
attack Trump and say he was bad at
everything it's it's it was a ridiculous
it was worse than that he he he had okay
it's worse than that he appointed his
own secretary of state A guy by the name
of cord bird so that cord bird could
then secretly and quietly Chang the
political handbook in Florida you could
look at Stu that's really happened it
used to be illegal in the state of
Florida for uh the transfer of funds
between a state pack to a federal pack
he appointed and hand selected his
secretary of state this guy Court bird
so that he could change the law then
that allowed for Ronda santis after
raising $200 million when he ran for the
second term as Governor of Florida to
train transfer the remain remaining $85
million over to the never backdown Super
Pac and then he ran a shadow
presidential campaign after he got a
book deal from uh rert Murdoch the owner
of Fox News Harper Collins and and you
know he he essentially now is an
absentee governor and he got the Florida
legislature to change the law we used to
have we have this law in Florida called
resign to run it still exists actually
where you had to resign if you wanted to
run for another position and so he had
the law changed so that it doesn't apply
if you want to run for president but it
still applies like say you are a member
of Congress like this happened to Byron
Donald's when Byron Donald's was a
Florida legislature he had to step down
when he ran for congress right and so if
this were any other lawmaker in Florida
the law still applies that's what
dictators do they change laws to benefit
themselves that's what Ron did and now
he's getting paid a his career's over
let him let him just
rest unfortunately for a few more years
you're beating the dead horse I want I
want move him as Governor I'm not going
to be happy until he's no longer
Governor wow wow I'm honestly that
pissed off you're going hard in the pay
I am so offended as a Florida taxpayer
that I have paid for this to
campaign on taxpayer dime while he has
divided uh the Republican party and
attack the best president this isn't
just about oh his career's over I am not
going to be happy until Governor Ronda
santis is literally working at a pizza
shop I want him out what if he's the
manager at like a cinema I want him out
his wife is going to try to run for
governor that this is a real thing I
just hold on hold on hold on I I got to
point this out I'm friends with Will
Chamberlain he's a good guy no he's not
I like will you don't have to like him
but this is important axios D santis
state funded office hires oued campaign
AIDS there is serious questions about
the desis campaign hiring Will
Chamberlain his wife Jordan who are
friends of ours and then when they left
the campaign got hired by his governor's
office despite working in the DC area I
I I I I think that's shady I'm sorry you
know look it seems very much like and
this is why axios wrote it the campaign
said we're laying people off laid off
campaign staff and then said we're going
to keep you doing the same work but pay
you through the governor's office yes
and that's what he's doing and it's a
total FEC violation Never Back Down has
been doing this you know they have rules
Tim cool off periods where you have to
wait technically speaking 120 days if
you want to transfer between a campaign
and a pack and if you notice if you look
at the records so many of Ronda Sis's
official campaign staff were then
working for the pack Never back down
this weekend he's had do you know that
Ronda santis on Saturday is flying in
his entire gubinatorial office to come
campaign for him that is illegal it's
illegal and nobody's holding him
accountable there's so many FEC
violations when you look at the fact
that Never Back Down You're supposed to
have a separation a firewall between a
pack and a campaign Never Back Down
essentially wrapped a tour bus and Ronda
santis is driving the bus like the
santis has been reincarnated and put
back into the dirt by you it's
unbelievable please leave the man alone
let him look look look let's show this
here Ronda santis is tied with vake in
the prediction markets Nikki Haley is
beating him by more than double and this
this not polls prediction markets which
I think in some ways you could argue are
better than polls or just different from
polls but I think it's fair to say I I
think the criticism is is is important
and at this point he should he should he
should drop out yeah I don't think he
will I don't think he'll drop out after
Iowa drop out if Iowa goes poorly for
him Iowa already stopped spending in New
Hampshire he's pulling at 5% and if you
look at the uh if you look at the
breakdown I actually uh tweeted a photo
of this the other day if you look at the
breakdown of political ad spending Ronda
santis has effectively ended all ad
spending in New Hampshire which is a
sign that he's going to drop out let me
make a a plea not really to the voters
so much as to the candidates uh we're
sitting in V's back room right now um we
don't need good we need great we need
great like it is it is such a dire
inflection point in American history if
not global history you have multiple
fronts for potential World War you have
a Global Financial reset that is like
imminently approaching you have no
fiscal constraints you have this
Mike who's the new uh whatever speaker
who's just such a bum um there's just no
there's no seriousness with which people
are approaching politics in fact the
only reason I got involved in podcasting
and being a political commentator was in
2020 because I realized it was so dire
that I wouldn't have a nation that I
could raise my children in peacefully
and I still don't have that we haven't
actually won anything in fact we're
losing extraordinarily rapidly I had a
hourong conversation Josie myself and
Donald Trump Jr last night very
impressed with him I honestly I had no
opinion of the guy really up until then
very open honest uh down to earth
stunningly Down to Earth for the son of
a billionaire nice guy I I think he gets
it and I all I'm asking is that I want
to see that reflected in his father if
he's going to be given a second turn at
the off we need great we need great and
if he's if he's able to deliver that he
just hasn't he hasn't shown me in his
rhetoric of late and maybe it's because
he's being pressured by so many uh you
know prosecutions and everything else
and the media is so unfair blah blah
blah okay fine it doesn't matter I need
you to be great I need you to be great
in this moment and if he can do that
then uh we'll see what what would that
look like greatness you need someone
who's extraordinarily serious about
either uh defending the dollar or or at
least dealing with the national debt in
a way that's very serious we have to
bring our troops home we cannot continue
to have troops sitting in Syria and Iraq
and there's most likely there's troops
also in Israel that are helping uh the
attacks on Gaza we need to stop having
all of our just these sitting ducks that
could be cas's belly for World War III
all over the Middle East it's totally
nuts we're also burning hundreds of
billions of dollars in Ukraine risking
World War III with the largest nuclear
power in the world in Russia but that's
not just all Donald Trump you see like
look you just said it yourself was bling
no Mike Johnson we need to hold the
Republican Party accountable the
Republican party has proven itself to be
completely ineffective and incompetent
unless Donald Trump is leading at the
top of the ticket okay Mike Johnson I
warned everybody I said I I honestly
vomited in my mouth when I saw president
Trump post on true social Maga Mike
because M Mike Johnson is a disgrace
he's not America First he's not Maga and
I would prefer that we never call Mike
Johnson Maga Mike because there's
nothing Maga about this guy you know we
have a speaker the house after after we
had a motion to vacate uh for Kevin
McCarthy we got Mike Johnson who did the
same exact thing we are what's the day
today the 12th we are 7 days away from a
government shutdown okay we don't have
any uh single single we don't have any
single Appropriations bills we have a $
1.6 trillion uh budget that the
Republicans are just like well whatever
I guess I guess we're just going to you
know sign off on a$ 1.6 trillion dollar
an open border no plan to militarize or
secure our border more money going to
Ukraine it's like we might as well just
just have a freaking Democrat speaker of
the house at this point in time
Republicans don't do this is the
point I'm trying to make is that the to
the American people like I just want to
make sure that they understand your
representatives don't care at all about
you and certainly not your children they
are setting you up to fail on a national
scale in a global depression and a
potential World War and we're just like
talking about it as opposed to being
like feel what I'm saying right now
we're on the cusp of a world war with
nuclear armed Powers all across the
planet nuts and we just like I I
I just I hope I hope that these people
actually understand the responsibility
that's being put at their feet I really
do well Trump always says in every
single speech he always says he's the
only candidate that can prevent World
War III and I truly do believe him I
mean we did see through his record and
you if you're Fair you'll agree with me
on this he didn't start any wars when he
was in the white house he's the only
president in my lifetime that entered
the White House and left the White House
without starting any new conflicts I
don't think the vake has the uh uh the
experience internationally to uh uh to
do the same thing for foreign policy
wise maybe not V says a lot of really
really great things we like his ideas we
like his policies FBI ETF etc etc Donald
Trump has decades upon Decades of
international business relations and
that experience he used to one it wasn't
just no new Wars it was the withdrawal
of our forces from many of these
countries it was getting NATO to pay
their fair share it was the Abraham
Accords negotiating with North Korea and
and and other quote unquote dictators
that the media didn't like the V great
the doesn't have that same degree of
experience Trump's Super Famous and he's
he's like a a rockar kind of so so Kim
Jong-un loves him like he just loves the
guy and that's a big deal having a North
Korean the dictator of North Korea
loving our president but you know what's
an even bigger deal is having a
president that is actually willing to go
after the three-letter agencies in this
country that are totally undermining
every constitutional protection that we
have I mean if you have if you have a
weaponized federal police force which is
what the FBI is and then you have the
ATF and the DEA and all these
unconstitutional illegal immoral
institutions that are willing to just
prosecute political dissidents all
across the board for years and they they
have nothing to fear they have nothing
to fear because they are ultimately able
to threaten our elected representatives
on top of everything else this is this
has to be addressed if if if it isn't we
don't have a country that's fact and we
have to be clear we don't want John
Bolton we don't want Mike Pompeo we
don't want Bill bar we don't want Nikki
Haley all those individuals were
appointed by Donald Trump there needs to
be push back against this there needs to
be criticism against this so it doesn't
happen again it's not hate it's not
derangement just I'm I need better than
what we got yeah I we can't have another
John Bolton in there we can't we can't
we can't we can't there's a lot at stake
here look I think that we also need to
recognize the fact that Donald Trump
right he's not a politician okay this is
a guy who ran for office you look at Joe
Biden he ran for president what three
times okay over the course of his
political career and so you have Donald
Trump who is a businessman he didn't
need this okay he's a iire could be
living a very glamorous lifestyle and he
ran for the first time he wins and I
think that you know there's I'm not
saying that President Trump's naive but
I think that when you win and you're
thrown into this and you're like wow I
really won and I'm president of the
United States now you're going to kind
of trust and think that the people in
the Republican Party are going to have
your back and what we all realized I
think we all kind of we didn't really I
mean we always knew there was a unip
party but it was really accelerated When
Donald Trump was in the white house
because we got to see firsthand wow the
Republicans are not just as evil as the
Democrats I think they're even worse
than the Democrats and they they they
surrounded Donald Trump and they
sabotaged him they undermined him we had
control of the house in the Senate his
first two years in the White House and
look what they did and I think that
Donald Trump learned a lesson this is a
guy who values loyalty and I think that
he expects the same type of loyalty from
others that he gives them and the rude
awakening that he had unfortunately was
that you can't expect people to be loyal
to you even if you are loyal to them
because these people are all snakes and
I don't know if president Trump is ever
going to necessarily admit that in full
because I think that he has somewhat of
a narcissistic personality I think
that's a good thing though you want the
president of the United States to be a
narcissist because you need to you need
to be the most powerful person in the
world and I don't think you get to that
position if you're not I don't think
there's anything wrong with being a
narcissist so I'm not attacking Trump
when I say he has a narcissistic
personality but sometimes when you have
that type of personality you don't want
to necessarily admit yeah this person
probably shouldn't have surrounded me
because they screwed me and I was the
person that appointed them Laura he
needs he needs a dozen of you in his his
office there is no one more ride or die
on Earth than you for Jo we're for Duty
he needs people around him that tell him
when he's wrong and people that disagree
with him that tell him why they disagree
exactly we're going to go to Super Chat
so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends and become a member at
timcast.net viewers like you uh a large
portion of what funds this operation our
ability to come to place like Iowa is
that you guys are members so if you like
the work we do you want to see us do
more more documentaries the coffee shop
is set to be opened around April and
that's act an actual number from the
company that's actually building it out
so we're excited for that congrats man
the new studio was was approved final
inspection is done now we're doing the
tech build out which means maybe by the
beginning of February we're in the new
building and it's all made possible
because people are members and as a
member you get access to our Discord
server where there's a ton of uh fans of
the show doing their own content hosting
their own shows so there's pre-shows
there's after shows there's always more
stuff for you to do if you become a
member and join that Discord server and
uh it's not just about supporting
tim.com but all the people who are in
our Discord server as members who are
building awesome stuff making music
making shows they ask me every day Tim
make sure you shout it out because we
want more people to join so they can
hang out with us and we can build
culture so let's read your super chats
voice of the people says Biden has filed
a motion to stop the Texas National
Guard from protecting their border the
president is openly and flagrantly
committing treason now seditious
conspiracy treason is aiding and
abetting an enemy in a time of conflict
sedition is trying to destroy or Unravel
a nation so I would call it a sedici
conspiracy Jacob par says ran Paul just
nuked Nikki Haley did you mean Nikki
Hillary yeah all right where we at she
might get excited about that hearing
nukes Raymond g Stanley J's gang anyone
leaving with a different view of the
Iowa caucus or maybe noteworthy
takeaways from everyone's time in Iowa #
never Nikki the caucus is Monday yeah I
got an interesting perspective because
being here I'm like oh VI's got this in
the bag like when you feel the energy
the people around you and that's like a
confirmation bias so it's like when
you're the the people you're surrounded
by can definitely make you think things
are going your way and I know that once
I pull out of this environment it's like
dude Trump was pulling at 78% on that
predicted Market well that's so that's
the those are predictions based on uh
how people feel about things and it's
like ask the audience and Who Wants To
Be A Millionaire here's what I would
love to see I've seen the photos from V
I know that he's doing event after event
after event I'd love to see second place
I'd love to see Nikki and DeSantis in
like low single digits and v in like 10%
and I think that it's a possibility I
think that Trump I've been saying this
because people have asked me all week
I've done a lot of interviews and people
say oh you know what's your feeling on
the ground just like the super chatter
just asked I think Trump's going to win
overwhelmingly I think that V is going
to shock everyone and come in second
because he like I said he's his work
ethic is amazing he's done over what 250
events in the last two weeks alone doing
12 events in one day and Nikki Haley and
Rond Des santis really don't have a lot
of people at their events I would know
because I've been thrown out of them but
you have a vake showing up Donald Trump
has the largest crowds and then it's
vake I think he's going to come in
second and then you're going to see
Nikki and uh Dan santis uh battle it out
for third and fourth the real ra Kam
Raul kamacho says what if as an
electoral strategy the doj arrests
enough j6 protesters from from Key
Battleground states to depress the chop
vote in November how can we track this
if indeed starts happening there's 1,700
or so convictions and they've promised
to do thousands more but even if they
got to around 10,000 people the issue
would have to be it's a good point
because we're not concerned about uh uh
I this strategy doesn't play well
nationally I think we're concerned about
the J Sixers generally but the concern
in the election would be if he goes to
like Ohio and arrests 5,000 people then
all of a sudden it's like okay hold on
there a minute now he's arresting likely
people who could vote uh against him so
that's when it gets scary uh tracking
that I suppose it's really difficult
it's really really difficult because
most people don't even know that they
can't even name four or five people who
have been convicted now of course you've
got you know Joe bigs you've got Enrique
tario we know about the higher profile
individuals but once again the main
issue is there were hundreds of
thousands of people there the doj is now
saying they're going to go after the
thousands of people who are standing
around and never went in the building
and we're not going to learn these
people's names because they don't have
the means to to get press and get
attention so it it is it is a good point
I don't think it'll play as big of a
role but we should definitely pay
attention did you say there have been
over a thousand uh conviction I I I read
from Time Magazine this was last year I
guess that there were over a thousand
people been arrested only 400 of them
had been convicted at that point 900 now
convictions I heard 1,700 convictions oh
really wow convictions and how many
arrests and didn't Matthew Graves just
the other day say that now they're going
to start arresting people that didn't
just go inside but were in the vicinity
so now you can be arrested and jailed
over j6 if you showed up so really what
okay I was wrong it was uh so far
730 convictions and then like what like
1,800 arrests or something 730 it was
not 1700 it's 730 I got that way wrong
and was it a th arrests is it has the
arrest number gone up 1,230 people it's
like that's like 40% so what is that
like 50 half the people that have been
arrested or have actually been convicted
the other half are just waiting for
three years they've just been waiting
without char No No it's not just that
there are some people who are getting
charged several years later and so
what's happening is interestingly
they're saying like there's a question
of the statute of limitations for some
of these crimes so now they're trying
other crimes that have longer statutes
of limitation the you know we I was
talking to someone I I'll put it this
way if you were there for any reason
lawyer up you're a journalist yeah nice
try saying but I had a press pass lawyer
up if you worked for the New York Times
okay yeah you'll be fine if you worked
for a conservative or independent Outlet
even with credentials even Congressional
credentials lawyer up but see what I
what I would like to see from Trump is
the the Congressional Representatives
that withheld exculpatory evidence on
behalf of of his supporters like why why
aren't we talking about Prosecuting
these people like that should if it's
not criminal I don't like how is it not
how is it not criminal to hold
exculpatory evidence it's the the entire
framing of this event was all predicated
off of withholding of the footage that
was only trickled out later on on which
is I think why many of these people have
have been given early release it's just
it's criminal it's obviously criminal
what's happened yeah well well you even
have people like uh like uh president
Buell of El Salvador which you know used
to be considered the most dangerous
country in the world known as a third
world hellhole and now he's completely
transformed it and people who are now
governing previous third world nations
are calling out our country for holding
political prisoners and having egregious
human rights violations so we can't
really be you know calling ourselves the
exporters of uh democracy or the world's
police or the world's moral Authority
because look we're no better I think
that we really are a third world country
now I don't know if you would agree but
what we don't have free speech we don't
have freedom of Association we don't
have free and fair elections we don't
really even have a free market economy
anymore when you look at the de Banking
and the uh financial blacklisting and we
have political prisoners well you
haven't had a free market since she had
a central bank but I completely agree
with you that on top of the financial
depravity we also have a total shredding
of our civil rights and and this has all
transpired in my lifetime from basically
from 911 on it has just been a rapid
descent and we are no longer that
shining City on the hill we are we are
now a warning to the rest of the world
as to what not to do that's tragic
that's tragic that I live in this
country because I I love this country
and I can't believe what's happening
just in my adult lifetime it's
unbelievable we got a super chat from
Billy Choo Biden admin is committing
treason right in front of us with the
open border allowing potential enemies
through the effort is to escalate the
Civil War to become hot before the next
election well I I I'm careful I say
sedition because it's generalized but
there is a good point to be made that
it's already been reported potential
terrorists uh people actually no
outright people on the terror watch list
have come through the southern border
with the bombing so we got news breaking
during the show actually that the US and
and UK engaged in additional air strikes
in Yemen this is go there's video of
hundreds of thousands of uh yemenis
protesting and and declare like calling
out the United States you are very
likely to see people try to come in to
hurt this country through this insecure
border but I will tell you this I
certainly fear the prospect of let's say
it civil war war why drink what did I
say hold on come on guys here's what
scares me I am not right about
everything all the time I'm wrong about
a lot of things I'm wrong a lot and I
love it the people in the chat are like
Tim thinks he's right if I'm arguing a
point that I think I'm right on of
course I think I'm right about that but
I think I'm wrong about a bunch of
things and so I know what happens next
but I got to tell you shout out to Dave
Smith when he came on the show and he
and he pointed this out to me and he
said shout out to you for something you
said on the Joe Rogan podcast that if
they kept up this kind of censorship and
manipulation this country is headed
towards Civil War now we have the
National Guard the Texas National Guard
deployed armed to block federal agents
from continuing their traffic operation
trafficking
operation my fear is we enter the point
where it's exactly what I said National
Guard is enforcing the law as per their
orders federal law enforcement enforces
the law as per their orders and you get
a guy in military gear a federal agent
walks up and says I got orders to clear
all you guys out of here let's say a
federal truck pulls up at APC guys jump
out in body armor and weapons and they
say CBP this is our jurisdiction it's a
federal border back the F up now and the
Texas state guys say no we we have
Governor's orders and we don't answer to
you my fear
is somebody shoot somebody
Federal Federal officers federal agents
in armor shooting at Texas National
Guard yeah I mean and that's that's a
moment that uh you don't really come
back from and I and and I'll tell you
how many people right now are going to
say oh that'll never happen if let's
let's play the time travel game I go
back eight years when Donald Trump is
running and I say to you eight years
from now Texas National Guard will be
armed and deployed to the southern
border to stop federal agents who are
facilitating human smuggling they're
gonna say shut up that's are you nuts
the states will never send out armed
military to to try and block federal
agents from from engaging in in
operations here we are but we're here
who who who would have ever thought that
Federal uh officials would be so
obviously going against like not just
the will of the nation but also uh their
their directives their responsibilities
in in in office that the states would
have to do this I mean that that's
really where at is like I there's
there's no doubt that like uh what's
Abbott Abbott didn't want to do this
like he feels compelled he feels that
there's the political will in his in his
State because the issue is so severe and
I don't blame him like this is if
there's one responsibility for a state
Governor it's to prevent Invasion and if
you have hundreds of thousands that are
coming across your border every month
you can't describe it as anything other
than Invasion yep and and it's we've
seen this years ago when they were
marching in huge groups of thousands
waving the banner of their countries and
I'm like hey that kind of looks like an
invasion and I got to tell you people
say but they're not armed it's you know
the listen Warfare does not people think
War means a guy with a gun shooting at a
guy with a gun war is the state of
conflict and a battle over resources
influence and control it takes many
forms the earliest eras of War it was
throwing rocks at each other it got to
the point of nuclear bombs but now we
have information Warfare yeah and so if
you were trying to invade country and
you know it doesn't matter what you call
it what matters is how do we win and if
you're like if we storm the Border armed
they'll mow us down with their more
powerful weapons if we manipulate the
psyche of the American people into
saying Help Help we're but harmless
refugees we can storm in and that's why
you don't come with weapons now they
can't do anything to stop you that's why
well and a lot of them are coming with a
weapon in their mind right the ideology
so look at the jihadists right that are
coming across you don't necessarily need
to have a physical weapon right to be
armed a lot of them are are armed with a
toxic ideology a backward ideology and
uh that's what you know they're trying
to push in our country and push all
around the world again I will reiterate
once again this is why we need president
Donald Trump back in the White House and
as you said earlier Tim you're worried
that you know people from Yemen are
going to try to uh retaliate now against
the United States by coming here well
who who had the solution to that Donald
J Trump with his travel ban right so we
got to get president Trump back in the
office he in in the white house he said
he's going to implement his travel ban
again to keep all these crazy jihadists
out of our country on day one and we
have Andrew ho the solution he says
sorry to burst your bubble every
president is a dictator for one day
their first day in office all they do is
sign dictatorial executive orders uh
agree and disagree I think the general
idea the founding fathers had with the
executives bran executive branch and
executive orders is brilliant I think
the modern version of it is corruption
the idea is actually really simple the
executive branch you're the
commander-in-chief you're in charge
charge of the Armed Forces and all its
branches and you oversee law enforcement
at the federal level which means
executive order could be like this from
now on DEA agents do not raid
dispensaries in in across the country
it's a waste of time and resources that
is not dictatorial that is the head of
law enforcement saying we're not going
to deal with that we're going to
priortize some prioritize something else
however to actually enforce a law you
need legislative legislature to
determine it so the general idea of an
executive order is fine except what's
happening now is things like Barack
Obama doing amnesty through executive
order and that's where we're at you get
Andrew cromo for instance in in New York
executive order you can't go to church
anymore and when they sue and say that
violates the First Amendment he goes
okay I'll take it down now I'm going to
make another one saying the exact same
thing sue me again that's dictatorial
and that's where we're at so I agree
exactly with what you're saying I think
it shouldn't be that way and the general
concept is fine but we've got too much
corruption I got to give one big big
credit to Donald Trump even though he
did it in the last year of his
presidency and I wish he had done it it
sooner but his executive order to remove
Barack Obama's executive order which
mandated that there be diversity Equity
inclusion departments in every Federal
agency in this nation that was huge that
was really really smart of him of course
Joe Biden undid it day one of his
presidency but I hope that Trump is is
uh preparing to to remove that once
again he is he said during his speech in
Iowa the other day I mean he's given
many speeches in Iowa but uh this last
week and I was there he said uh that
we're going to restore Merit in our
country and he was you know emphasizing
the fact that we need to uh start hiring
people that are qualified uh for their
positions as opposed to giving people
positions based off the color of their
skin or their sexual orientation we have
a good one here Michael a says I'm an
anchor baby and I served in the military
for eight years from 2001 to 2008 Laura
wants to deport me why I am more
American than she will ever be I'm an
immigrant who served the country during
war man explain to me why does Laura
want me deported please well I'm talking
about our constitution as as it relates
to Nikki Haley being president of the
United States right we were talking
about people who were qualified to uh be
president and per our Constitution and
the founding fathers you have to be a
natural born citizen to be a
natural-born citizen one of your parents
has to be a citizen at your at your time
of birth both of Nikki Haley's parents
at the time of her birth uh were were
were were not citizens of the United
States they had been in this country
from India I believe for only 3 years
before she was born her mother didn't
even try to become a citizen until 2003
free and so technically speaking right
she's what we call she she she is what
we call an anchor baby she has
Birthright citizenship and that's one of
the reasons why our country is being
invaded right now because there's been a
bastardization and a reinterpretation of
what it means to be a natural-born
citizen and people want to bend the
rules and give citizenship to people who
are anchor babies and yeah okay you
served our country thank you so much for
your service but the reality is is that
we are no
I'm I'm saying that we we need to have a
serious conversation going forward in
this country we have not enforced our
laws or our lawmakers have not enforced
the laws and as a result now we have
been overrun by migrants who are rep
replacing the actual Natural Born
populations of the United States of
America with with themselves okay coming
and having 10 kids according to United
States V Wong Kim Arc Supreme Court
ruling you are a natural born citizen if
you were born on us soil regardless of
your parental your parent citizenship
status now that's a Supreme Court ruling
and so the argument that we're seeing
now is the founding fathers never
intended for that to be the case yeah so
an argument was made based on the 14th
Amendment of the Supreme Court the
Supreme Court agreed your parents don't
have to be citizens if you're born here
you're a citizen I think that's wrong
citizen however you're a Birthright
citizen you're not a natural-born
citizen well so so you're a citizen of
you're born here regardless of whether
your parents are citizens but that's
that's what we're talking about right
the difference between Birthright
citizenship and natural-born citizenship
but no I I don't I don't see the
distinction I'm I'm saying the founding
fathers I do not believe intended for it
to be anyone could just come here give
birth and then bang that kid like let's
let's be honest Native American in
living in a city in in you know in in
the 1 late 1700s had a kid they did not
believe that kid was a citizen that kid
they're like you're Native American
you're not you're not a citizen of of
our of our country and it changed after
the 40th Amendment after the Civil War
then the Supreme Court ruling these
things are entirely interpretable but I
would say this um I don't think someone
like Michael should deported someone who
was born here grew up here loves this
country served this country is exactly
the kind of person we need and I think
the concern I have I'm I'm not uh
anti-immigration I I would love to I got
a PR I don't think he should be deported
either for the record because I don't
want to be accused of not answering his
question I'm I'm talking about the
people that are coming across our border
you know a lot of people plan their
Journeys to America uh with their with
their pregnancy they say okay I'm going
to get pregnant and then I'm going to
make my journey across the border and
then I'm going to give birth and then
they're going to make me stay because
what are they going to do separate me
and my child that's that's immigration
fraud and we shouldn't be allowing for
criminal illegal alien Invaders I I I
have an idea how about our immigration
program is not a moratorium we allow
immigration but we can only allow one
new immigrant who comes in Legally
through a process they have a certain
amount of time to learn and pass a
Civics test but a leftist has to
leave I'm I'm totally on board could you
imagine what about the can we send some
rhinos too I want to get rid of a lot of
Republicans too not just I love this
meme where it's like some socialist
antifa person goes to Venezuela as an an
exchange program the people desperate to
flee this country who want to be
American so desperately will take them
and the the American leftist commies can
go to Venezuela and then we're better
off works for
me but what's the problem I mean if
they're Communists they'd be like I'd
love to go live in this this socialist
Utopia right go to China enjoy yeah Cuba
Cuba's over Venezuela all right place
467 Sprite says 26 Maga anchor baby here
from Anaheim we're part of the silent
majority as well our parents came to
America for its prosperity and freedoms
I see no point in their sacrifice if it
rots we exist to save it what happens to
us and I want to hold on there a minute
if your parents came here legally and
then gave birth to you you are not an
anchor baby but if you are actually
saying your parents came here illegally
because of its Prosperity its freedoms
this it this is not good okay this is
someone who said I don't care for your
country's laws I will I want prosperity
and I will I I will take the prosperity
by breaking your laws we call that theft
we call that crime see unless you're
Nikki unless you're Nikki Haley because
she said I'm sure you saw the video
right did you see the video of Nikki
Haley saying that we shouldn't be
calling illegal aliens criminals they're
not criminals they're just people who
want a better life so I guess the
criminal illegal alien that you know
that gang raped a 5-year-old girl right
he's not a criminal he just wants a
better life by raping little girls let's
say I go to uh my good friend Clint over
here and say I I would like that phone
uh how about uh I do what can I do to
get that phone and you say here is the
process by which I accept the transfer
of my phone to you I say okay I will
engage in that now there's the
alternative which is illegal immigration
where I walk up grab the phone and run
yeah look the coming into this country
illegally may be because it's for its
freedom and prosperity but you're
basically saying you're taking from
taking it from the community by force
now as for you 4 467 Sprite I got I got
nothing against you you're an American
you love America you were born here you
believe in this country it's founding
fathers it's vision if your parents
assimilated and really did believe in it
it's a good thing I still would
say it's fine to say there's a
difference between uh uh someone who
comes here illegally for Buffalo Wild
Wings which is I'm not making that up an
illegal immigrant was was interviewed
and said I want BDubs and someone saying
America is The Shining City on the hill
who believe in Civil Rights and Freedoms
and I will do anything to get there
there's a difference between those
people and I can respect that but I
would simply say look man if you come
here illegally you are not respectfully
asking us to to bring you into the fold
you are insulting and disrespecting us
well I I don't totally disagree but I
will say this if it comes down to a
bunch of Cubans that are fleeing
communism like I I don't care that like
the Pres yes the first foot that they
make on this on this soil will be
illegal but I still think that's a net
benefit to this country because these
are people that are are really sincerely
like to the point that they're willing
to risk their lives that's how much they
oppose communism I love those people I
mean we have homeless veterans sleeping
on uh bank robbers are will to risk
their lives to steal we don't we don't
say oh it's so honorable and Noble you
risk your life to take money from but
it's no but it's because it's they're
not trying to steal they're trying to uh
actually like uphold the American value
set but they're going to be a burden on
our system because let's be honest
they're coming from communism they don't
have any money they're going to need
they're going to need somebody to
support them I mean look you can have
this humanitarian spirit and want to
help people and say Well they're fling
communism but who's going to be paying
their bills it's going to be us I don't
want to pay their bills I don't I want
with this because if if we're going to
start start going down that PA I would
greatly prefer to see like ivy league
college graduates deported and bring in
Cubans like honestly like I the country
would be way better off if every ivy
league graduate was just immediately
deported to China and we were just
bringing in people from communist
Nations that really true it's not really
no it would be totally better it
wouldn't I am 100% serious I'm not
saying it would be like I'm not sure I'm
not saying it would be legal I'm not
saying I would actually advocate for it
I'm just saying outcome wise our country
would be way better off if the Marxist
kids that are coming out of college were
just immediately launched into outer
space it'd be tremendously better now
hold on can we set up like a moon base
yeah no of course they're going to be
safe up there I'm not trying to hurt no
no no no no hold on hold on no I I was
being cute I'm like this is a program I
can get behind we create a moon base in
a Mars colony and we're like we are
going to have you guys colonize the moon
then Mars and I'll tell you why it is
not because I want to laugh haha we're
going to blast him off the moon I think
uh roughing it in a little hardship will
toughen them up yeah give them a good
understanding of what it means to to be
responsible for yourself and but but
also they may actually agree to it
because it's an honor to be the first
human to colonize this is a problem with
all this illegal immigration is it's
turning people off from accepting actual
refugees people that are are literally
fleeing their own demise and death from
tyranny like but where from Mexico or
Canada I I don't even care Earth at this
point like if they're real
refug no no no stop stop stop stop
stop okay pause pause pause if someone
from Mexico is being attacked by the
cartels and they come to me and they say
please save me this man's going to kill
me I say okay what can I do if someone
from Canada says Justin Trudeau is is is
going to kill me I need help I say okay
those aren't real refugees they are are
not a real Refugee is a guy who comes
from Africa and pays three grand to fly
to South America takes a a bus all the
way through Mexico and then comes to our
border they're not real Refuge that's my
point these people are claiming Refugee
status but they're not real refugees if
they come from Mexico you said those
people aren't refugees I said they are
if there is a real Refugee that needs
this my point why I ask
what's it that's why I asked Mexico or
if it depends on the situation like if
Trudeau is literally hunting a man down
and going to kill him and the guy fle to
the US okay yeah but they are though I
would rather take political refugees in
America as opposed to from the from the
Western world as opposed to these third
world migrants who are saying that
Canadians Canadians are beinged there's
people going to jail in in Canada for
misgendering people I'm sorry but that
to me is that's more of I would consider
somebody like that to be more of a
refugee in need of Asylum than some
third world migrant who just wants to
come come move to the United States of
America there is no question when Mexico
offered Asylum to all these people in
the Caravan there's a video of them
asking how many of you want to stay here
get amnesty in Mexico nobody how many of
you want to continue to America yay they
all cheer and scream they're not
refugees yeah they're not a lot of these
people are claiming Refugee status and
they're not even being questioned like
so the issue is this you are correct
but there really are no Mexican and
Canadian refugees it would probably be
in the in the triple digits
it's 100 people maybe if there was a
Civil War in a country you could see a
lot of those people fleeing you could
see maybe Ukrainian refugees maybe
people from Gaza no they don't come here
why if you're in Ukraine and you're fing
you go to Poland they're next door you
don't fly across the world to America
that's a lie if someone's dealing with
problems in Honduras you go to Mexico
you go to or not even that you go to
Guatemala why are they skipping through
Mexico is Awesome by the way Luke knows
it I love Mexico this is this is what
deeply offended me because I go to
Mexico City and I'm like it's a
beautiful massive City and they got
BDubs all over the place then I watch I
I see this video of them saying no we
won't stay a journalist interviews one
of the migrants saying why are you
coming to America and he said I miss
Buffalo Wild Wings and I'm like bro they
got that in
Mexico it's amazing to me that you go to
Tijana you go to Mexico City and it's a
beautiful place with great people and
they actually have cheaper Healthcare
these people who are coming through they
are lying to our faces that they're
refugees lying to our faces so if you're
from Syria if you're from Afghanistan if
you're from Iraq and you were forced out
of your country due to conflict guess
what lebanon's right there waiting for
you I knew I I I met people who I I
talked to two refugees from Syria and
they went to one of them went to Romania
one went to Turkey and they were good
dudes I respect them you know they're
nice and I asked why why go to Romania
because you get access to the to Europe
and there's more money said I I met a
guy he was telling me he knew a woman
who didn't speak any European language
she spoke Arabic and she had an option
Lebanon or Europe she chose Europe I
said why well because Europe's nicer and
I'm like but you could actually go to
Lebanon speak the language get a job
there you're you're you're Mo you're
it's it's easier to assimilate now
you're in a country where you don't
speak they don't want to assimilate
that's the thing they don't these people
don't want to assimilate that's the
problem there's plenty of Lebanese
people assimilate in in Europe at this
point dude it's really simple man you're
living in a big mansion and you're in
the you're you're paying hundred bucks a
month to sleep under the stairs in the
basement and some dude upstairs is
paying 500 bucks a month for for a nice
one-bedroom and you're like I'd rather
live up there it's comfortable there's a
TV so you kick the door in and you say
I'm staying here do something about it
that's what they're doing fleeing the
shadows in the closet well this is why
you can't have policies that make it at
all possible for people to just come
here with their hands out if you have
that you're going to create this crisis
and and the Biden Administration and
many administrations prior have
continued this process and it has to be
stopped that's why we need to ban
Birthright citizenship and I'll say it
again every single GOP candidate for
president supports Banning Birthright
citizenship except Nikki Haley and the
only reason why she doesn't support it
is because that would mean that she
wouldn't be a citizen because she
herself is a Birthright Citizen and
she's not qualified to be president
she's not a natural born citizen
president Trump even shared the article
the other day uh that I wrote that was
repurposed on Gateway pundit explaining
this so you know we can't have her not
just for her foreign policy but also
because Nikki Haley herself because she
was granted Birthright citizenship she
has sympathy for these people that want
to come and criminally invade our
country and take over and you know just
completely completely take over and
replace us we we can't allow that I'm
going to read of identity one last Super
Chat three if by treachery says every
time Tim talks about going to Super
chats he sounds like the PBS intro
viewers like you Tim you are a boss
let's get that intro to Super chats
different than government propaganda my
friend that's the joke that's I also say
would you kindly smash the like button
which which is a Bioshock reference so
when I say this show is funded in part
by viewers like you it's because I grew
up watching PBS in Chicago interesting
thank you for for hanging out so if you
haven't already would you kindly aha
smash that like button and I'm gonna I'm
Gonna Fill you guys in BioShock is one
of the best video games ever played ever
made uh Luke you definitely need to play
Bioshock because uh very libertarian
yeah very libertarian and um that one of
the components of it considering it's
like a 20-some year old video game
spoiler alerts the character is mind
controlled whenever he's asked would you
kindly do something he is compelled to
do it so the bad guy would if if someone
said do a backflip he'd be like what we
said would you kindly do a backflip he
asked to do it so would you kindly smash
that like button you can follow the show
at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast uh Laura you want
to shout anything out yeah um I uh have
a show on Rumble it's called Lumar
Unleashed and so it's every Tuesday and
Thursday at 8:00 p.m. Eastern so be sure
you follow my Rubble Channel rumble.com
Laur ler and then follow me of course on
X and true social gab and getter at
Laura lomer Laura thank you so much for
coming I'm going to make a a t-shirt
saying I survived the screaming match
with Laura lomer on the best political
shirts.com no one's ever survived though
uh nobody ever survives Luke oh man uh
but uh me and Clinton have a show uh
you're welcome to come on the show as
well we could argue and scream at each
other all the time uh more importantly
uh rest in peace Gonzalo l i I wish we
had more time to talk about him we
talked about him on the best political
show for uh a very long time uh check
out that conversation it just ended a
few moments ago uh the best political
show.com that's my website subscribe
100K Clint get give quick shout out to
real Hydro PX this dude I love you buddy
you're look man your tweets your super
chats make me laugh he's just like
constantly attacking and roasting me I I
know I I'm at all of and roasting me too
very heavily and I'm like if you're
going to roast me roast me on the bestp
political show.com
no no I've seen it like every every 5
minutes I'm like damn another one
another one I forgot to say uh you know
the Iowa caucus is in three days and so
uh please don't take it for granted we
really need president Trump to win and
so please don't let the snow stop you
from getting out and voting for
president Trump if you need to learn how
to caucus you have to live in Iowa if
you want to caucus you can go to ia.
donaldjtrump.com IIA is an iowa.
donaldjtrump.com uh and you can learn
anyone can do this right well only if
you live in Iowa no that's what I mean
like residents of Iowa can come out for
this stuff yeah and if you're a Democrat
cuz I know you have Democrats that watch
your show too you're allowed to do same
day registration changes to vote in the
caucus in Iowa so you can actually
change your registration to Republican
and vote for Donald Trump in the Iowa
caucus right because we need to save our
country and Donald Trump's the only one
that's going to do it uh I am at Liberty
lock pod on X and if you go to your
phone right there and you put in liberty
lockdown and hit subscribe on your
podcast here that'd be great and then
while you're there do the best iCal show
and then hit subscribe and then do to
gang don't do toar gang um we Luke and I
will actually be on the road following V
ramas Swami's team for the entire day
yesterday that'll all be over on we are
change on Rumble all one word we are
change uh thank you so much for having
me Tim it was great thank you for coming
Clint and definitely subscribe to Tower
gang check out we are change uh the best
political show they did a episode with
Mike cernovich and talking about iasa
for an hour it was so good wild oh I
want more psychedelics on this show
let's make it happen 2024 is the year
Laura lomer last thank you very much
yeah thanks for having me last Super
Chat the real Hydra says you know I love
you all right everybody anytime thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all on
Monday for our Big Show with a live
audience it's going to be an extra hour
long we're not doing the members only
because we're doing a three-hour show
from 8 to 11: it's going to be epic and
we will see you all then thanks for
hanging
out